At Miele, our partner is the planet. Our appliances use less water and energy and are tested to last the equivalent of 20 years of use. That's the ultimate form of sustainability. I'm Nelson Fresco, President and CEO of Miele Canada. Until June 30th, every purchase of a Miele dishwasher or laundry machine supports the preservation and restoration of Canadian forests through the Miele Forest Initiative.
在美诺（Miele），我们的合作伙伴就是地球。我们的家电用水量和能耗更低，且经过测试，其使用寿命相当于20年。这才是可持续发展的终极形式。我是美诺加拿大公司总裁兼首席执行官尼尔森·弗雷斯哥（Nelson Fresco）。在6月30日之前，购买任何美诺洗碗机或洗衣机，都将通过美诺森林倡议（Miele Forest Initiative）支持加拿大森林的保护和修复。
Join us in making an impact today for a better tomorrow. Visit Miele.ca to learn more. Okay Martin, let's try one. Remember, big. You got it. The Ford It's a Big Deal event is on. How's that? A little bigger. The Ford It's a Big Deal event. Nice. Now the offer? Lease a 2025 Escape Active All-Wheel Drive from 198 bi-weekly at 1.99% APR for 36 months with $27.55 down. Wow! That's like $99 a week!
加入我们，共创今天的影响力，以换取更美好的明天。访问 Miele.ca 了解更多信息。好了，马丁，我们来试一个。记住，要夸张。明白。“福特‘大事发生’（It's a Big Deal）活动正在进行中。”感觉怎么样？再大一点。“福特‘大事发生’活动！”很好。现在说优惠？租赁2025款 Escape Active 全轮驱动版，双周仅需 198 加元起，年利率 1.99%，租期 36 个月，首付 27.55 加元。哇！那简直就像每周 99 加元！
Yeah, it's a big deal! The Ford It's a Big Deal Event! Visit your Toronto area Ford store or Ford.ca today. I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of The Office with exclusive interviews, behind the scenes details and lots of VFF stories.
没错，这可是一件大事！福特“大事发生”活动！今天就访问您大多伦多地区的福特经销商或访问 Ford.ca。我是珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer），我是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》（The Office），而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你带来了这档终极办公室爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量 VFF 故事，深入探讨《办公室》的世界。
We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello everybody! Hi! VFF stories. We're the Office Ladies 6.0. Hello everybody! Hi! Welcome to Office Ladies 6.0, All About Stanley Hudson. You know, National Pretzel Day is coming up. It's Saturday, April 26th, and we thought what better way to honor National Pretzel Day than to do our All About Stanley Hudson episode. I mean, Stanley does love pretzel day. Loves. Angela, did you know that Pretzel Day originated in Pennsylvania? I did not know that.
我们是《办公室女士》6.0 版。大家好！嗨！VFF 故事。我们是《办公室女士》6.0 版。大家好！嗨！欢迎收看《办公室女士》6.0 版，全方位了解斯坦利·哈德森（Stanley Hudson）。你知道吗，全国椒盐卷饼日（National Pretzel Day）快到了。就在4月26日星期六，我们觉得，没有什么比制作我们的“全方位了解斯坦利·哈德森”特别节目更好的方式来庆祝全国椒盐卷饼日了。我是说，斯坦利确实很喜欢椒盐卷饼日。超爱。安吉拉，你知道椒盐卷饼日发源于宾夕法尼亚州吗？我不知道。
I didn't either, but according to the internet, which is our favorite way to reference facts. That's how I reference things. Thank you. 2003 Pennsylvania Governor Ed Rendell and former Philadelphia mayor declared April 26th National Pretzel Day to recognize the importance that pretzels have to the Pennsylvania state history. It is believed that the hard pretzel, not the soft pretzel, but like hard pretzels, were invented in Pennsylvania in 1850 by German immigrants.
我也不知道，但根据互联网的说法——这是我们最喜欢的查阅事实的方式。我就是这样查阅资料的。谢谢。2003年，宾夕法尼亚州州长埃德·伦德尔（Ed Rendell）和前费城市長宣布4月26日为全国椒盐卷饼日，以表彰椒盐卷饼对宾夕法尼亚州历史的重要意义。据信，硬椒盐卷饼（不是软椒盐卷饼，而是那种硬的椒盐卷饼）是1850年由德国移民在宾夕法尼亚州发明的。
Huh. I got another stat for you. Okay. Well here it is and I found this staggeringly interesting. Pennsylvania produces 80% of the country's hard and soft pretzels. 80%? 80%! Of the United States of America, pretzel making happens in Pennsylvania. That's right. Wow. And apparently, Pennsylvanians eat more pretzels per capita than any other state in the United States. Really?
哈。我还有另一个数据要告诉你。好吧。事情是这样的，我发现这令人震惊地有趣。宾夕法尼亚州生产了全国 80% 的硬质和软质椒盐卷饼。80%？80%！美国制造的椒盐卷饼有很大一部分都产自宾夕法尼亚州。没错。哇。而且显然，宾夕法尼亚人的人均椒盐卷饼消费量是美国其他任何州都无法比拟的。真的吗？
They make them and then they eat them. In fact, Pennsylvanians consume 12 times more pretzels than the average American. How do they measure that? I mean, come on. But hey, listen, look at the enthusiasm for the pretzel cart on Pretzel Day in Scranton, Pennsylvania. Yeah. Pennsylvanians love their pretzels. It's true. It is true. Well, you know, Josh has a great pretzel bite recipe. Oh, I know about those. I will share it in stories. I told him kind of late in the game that we were doing this. He was like, and I would have made you all pretzel bites.
他们生产，然后他们吃掉。事实上，宾夕法尼亚人消耗的椒盐卷饼是普通美国人的 12 倍。他们是怎么测算这个的？我是说，拜托。不过嘿，听着，看看宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿椒盐卷饼节上人们对椒盐卷饼的热情。对。宾夕法尼亚人真的一点也离不开椒盐卷饼。是真的。确实如此。哦，你知道的，乔什有一个很棒的椒盐卷饼小吃食谱。哦，我知道那些。我会在动态（stories）里分享。我挺晚才跟他说我们在做这个主题的。他的反应是：“天哪，早说的话我就会给你们做椒盐卷饼小吃了。”
You know what? No one wants to hear us eat anymore. Did you see the comments? I did. I did. And I said, babe, it's okay. We can't eat on the podcast anymore. People loved all about Kevin Malone, but they're like, I didn't need to listen to them eat
你知道吗？没人想听我们吃东西了。你看到评论了吗？我看到了。我看到了。然后我说，宝贝，没关系。我们不能在播客里吃东西了。大家都很喜欢关于凯文·马隆（Kevin Malone）的那期，但他们的反应是：我不需要听他们吃
chili. Don't eat anymore. Well, here's, here's something I wanted to share with you guys. The folks that make pretzels, they honor National Pretzel Day as well, and there are some great deals on pretzels on April 26th. Auntie Anne's offers their rewards members with an in-app coupon for a free original or cinnamon sugar pretzel in store on April 26th. No purchase required.
辣椒。别再吃了。好吧，这里有一点，这里有些我想和大家分享的事情。制作椒盐卷饼的人们也同样庆祝全国椒盐卷饼日，4月26日这天有一些关于椒盐卷饼的超棒优惠。安缇安（Auntie Anne's）为他们的奖励计划会员提供了一张应用内优惠券，4月26日当天可在店内免费兑换一份原味或肉桂糖椒盐卷饼。无需任何消费。
You just have to sign up for their rewards program to make sure you get that coupon sent to your account. And Wetzel's Pretzels will celebrate National Pretzel Day and by the way their 30th anniversary this year. They're going to offer free original pretzels to all customers at participating locations starting at 3 p.m. until closing. They also call it National Wetzel Day. And they come on Wetzel's Pretzels. I know. And they're gonna have a sweepstakes this year. They have what's called a Wetz party where five winners will receive a Wetzel's Pretzels for a year. Free Wetzel's Pretzels for a year. Wow. Mm-hmm. So lots of folks celebrating National Pretzel Day and I
你只需注册他们的奖励计划，就能确保将该优惠券发送到你的账户中。韦策尔椒盐卷饼（Wetzel's Pretzels）将庆祝全国椒盐卷饼日，顺便提一下，今年也是他们成立 30 周年。他们将在下午 3 点直到打烊，向所有参与门店的顾客免费赠送原味椒盐卷饼。他们还将这一天称为“全国韦策尔日”（National Wetzel Day）。而且，天哪，韦策尔椒盐卷饼。我懂。他们今年还将举办抽奖活动。他们举办所谓的“韦茨派对”（Wetz party），五位获胜者将获得一整年的韦策尔椒盐卷饼。免费一整年的韦策尔椒盐卷饼。哇。嗯哼。所以有很多人在庆祝全国椒盐卷饼日，我
read to that check your local stores that make pretzels because they usually have their own thing too. I love some free stuff. I get very excited when I know that I can get like free food somewhere. I know you on National Doughnut Day. Oh yeah, Krispy Kreme. Mm-hmm. Go there. And also on 7-Eleven you can get a free slushie at 7-Eleven. Oh, that's a good one, too. Well, Jenna, I know you usually like to kick off our all-about episodes with the show Bible Summary, but before you do that, I wanted to share a piece of mail that we got recently.
听说去查查你当地制作椒盐卷饼的店，因为他们通常也有自己的活动。我很喜欢免费的东西。当我得知自己能在某个地方弄到免费食物时，我会非常兴奋。我知道你对全国甜甜圈日（National Doughnut Day）的态度。哦，对，克里斯皮克雷姆（Krispy Kreme）。嗯哼。去那儿。而且在7-11便利店，你还可以在7-11免费获得一杯思乐冰。哦，那个也很不错。好吧，珍娜，我知道你通常喜欢以“剧本圣经摘要”（show Bible Summary）来开启我们的“全方位了解”节目，但在你这么做之前，我想分享一封我们最近收到的信。
It's a letter from Kathy L., and it's really special. Oh, yes, I know what this is. She said she has only just started listening and loves the podcast and she might be giving Dr. Thibodeau a run for his money as the ultimate Office Ladies tracker because listen to what she did. Sam Cassie, I can't even get over this. She wrote and said, I thought I would try to document all that you said in at least season one of the Office Ladies podcast. And she made a book called The Podcast Bible. Look at it! Look, our picture's on the front. It says The Office Ladies Podcast Bible, season one. I'm going to share this in stories. Oh my goodness, Kathy, the time you spent on this. It's amazing. I was flipping through it and she has all of our like banter moments and
这是一封来自凯茜·L（Kathy L.）的信，非常特别。哦，是的，我知道这是什么。她说她最近才开始收听并非常喜欢这个播客，而且她可能正在给蒂博多医生（Dr. Thibodeau）构成威胁，成为终极《办公室女士》追踪者，因为听听她都做了什么。萨姆、凯茜，我简直不敢相信。她写道：“我想试着记录下你们在《办公室女士》播客第一季中所说的一切。”她制作了一本名为《播客圣经》（The Podcast Bible）的书。快看！看，我们的照片在封面呢。上面写着《办公室女士播客圣经，第一季》。我会在动态里分享这个。哦天哪，凯茜，你花在这个上面的时间。太惊人了。我翻看了一下，她把我们所有的那些闲聊时刻以及
facts and tidbits all in book form. It's so cool. And she'll have like the synopsis and a photo from that episode. It's really well done. Thank you very much. We loved this. I love this and I'm so excited to show it to my kids because I think it's like this tangible representation of the podcast. Yeah. Well, speaking of show Bibles, Angela, we did get this fan question from Alexander G. in Houston, Texas, who said, I recently listened to the Office Olympics episode and recalled
事实和趣闻都做成了书的形式。太酷了。而且她还会有剧情简介和该集的一张照片。真的做得很好。非常感谢。我们太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢了，我非常高兴能把它展示给我的孩子们，因为我觉得这就像是播客的有形呈现。嗯。说到剧本圣经，安吉拉，我们确实收到了来自德克萨斯州休斯顿的亚历山大·G（Alexander G.）的粉丝提问，他说，我最近听了《办公室奥运会》（Office Olympics）那一集，想起了
the show Bible and how Jenna stole it from Greg Daniels. I need to say, guys, I didn't steal it. It was given to me. I love, though, this image of you sneaking into his office and rummaging around. I know. Alexander said, Please, please, please read us Stanley's section of the show Bible. I love Leslie David Baker's character and Stanley is always so funny. All right, Alexander, here it is. Stanley Hudson is a sales rep at Dunder Mifflin Paper Company and as of season four had been at Dunder Mifflin for 10 years. His birthday is the week of
剧本圣经以及珍娜是如何从格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）那里把它偷走的。我必须说，伙计们，我没有偷。是别人给我的。不过我好喜欢这种画面：你偷偷溜进他的办公室到处翻找。我知道。亚历山大说：“求求你、求求你、求求你给我们读读剧本圣经里关于斯坦利的部分吧。我超喜欢莱斯利·大卫·贝克（Leslie David Baker）的角色，斯坦利总是那么搞笑。”好的，亚历山大，它来了。斯坦利·哈德森是邓德米夫林纸业公司（Dunder Mifflin Paper Company）的销售代表，截至第四季，他已经在邓德米夫林工作了10年。他的生日在
July 21st. He is Catholic and he grew up in a small town. Here are some of his likes. Oh, I can't wait. Is it a short list? Shorter than the dislikes! You know it! His likes are red wine. In fact, he has a glass of red wine with dinner once a week for the antioxidants. He also loves red wine in a bath. He likes mystery stories, crossword puzzles, pretzels, and chocolate ice cream. That's literally all of the likes. Okay, I can't get behind all of those, but now I'm buckling in for the dislikes. Dislikes. When asked to give feedback, he has a lot of complaints.
7月21日那一周。他是天主教徒，在一个小镇长大。以下是他的一些喜好。哦，我等不及了。这是一个简短的列表吗？比讨厌的东西短！你懂的！他喜欢红葡萄酒。事实上，他每周晚餐时会喝一杯红葡萄酒来摄取抗氧化剂。他也喜欢在泡澡时喝红葡萄酒。他喜欢悬疑小说、填字游戏、椒盐卷饼和巧克力冰淇淋。这就是所有的喜好。好吧，我无法接受所有这些，但我现在要系好安全带迎接讨厌的东西了。讨厌的东西。当被要求提供反馈时，他有很多抱怨。
For example, he filed a complaint that Phyllis cries too much and it bugs him. But he's never said a word about Phyllis' stinky perfumes, no matter how much they bother him. So I guess he does show some restraint sometimes. He doesn't usually enjoy theater. He doesn't dress up for Halloween and he threw out his Dundies. He refuses to participate in grief counseling. He thinks his bed is too small, his daughter's school is too expensive, and he believes he's underpaid. He also has a lot of health issues.
例如，他投诉菲利丝（Phyllis）哭得太多，这让他很烦。但无论菲利丝的刺鼻香水味多么困扰他，他从未对此说上半个字。所以我想他在某些时候确实表现出了一些克制。他通常不喜欢戏剧。他万圣节不化妆，还把他的邓迪奖（Dundies）扔掉了。他拒绝参加悲伤辅导。他认为他的床太小了，女儿的学校太贵了，而且他觉得自己薪水过低。他还有很多健康问题。
Oh. He has type 2 diabetes, varicose veins, swollen ankles, and nipple sensitivity. What? Yeah. I can't remember what episode that's from, but it's in the show Bible. And Stanley has a heart attack at work. Hmm. Finally, he is quite the ladies man. Yes. But I'll be breaking that down in more detail a little bit later. In your area of interest? Correct, Angela. In my area of interest.
哦。他患有2型糖尿病、静脉曲张、脚踝肿胀和乳头敏感。什么？对。我记不清那是哪一集里的了，但它就在剧本圣经里。而且斯坦利在工作时心脏病发作。嗯。最后，他是个十足的女人缘极佳的人。对。但我稍后会更详细地剖析这一点。在你感兴趣的领域？没错，安吉拉。在我感兴趣的领域。
What is your area of interest? Stanley origin story and family. What's your area of interest? I called mine the Stanley shutdown. Well, why don't we take a break and then we'll get to it. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. So here's how it works. With BetterHelp, you can pay a flat fee for weekly sessions and that's going to save you big time on cost and time,
你感兴趣的领域是什么？斯坦利起源故事和家庭。你感兴趣的领域是什么？我把我的叫做“斯坦利关机”（The Stanley shutdown）。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下，然后再继续呢。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。事情是这样的。通过 BetterHelp，你可以为每周的咨询支付固定费用，这将大大节省你的成本和时间，
because therapy should feel accessible. And with online therapy, you get quality care at a price that makes sense. And with over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform and has served over 5 million people globally. And it's convenient. You can join a session with a click of the button, and it helps you to fit therapy into your busy life. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge.
因为治疗应该让人感到亲切。通过在线治疗，你可以以合理的价格获得优质的护理。BetterHelp 拥有超过 30,000 名治疗师，是全球最大的在线治疗平台，已为全球超过 500 万人提供过服务。而且它很方便。只需点击一下按钮，你就可以加入会议，这有助于将治疗融入你忙碌的生活中。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与有执照的治疗师进行匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。
Your well-being is worth it, and if you are thinking of starting therapy, you can give BetterHelp a try. Visit betterhelp.com slash office ladies today to get 10% off your first month. My parents have had a lot of time on their hands lately. At first, it was nice. Hey mom, can you drive me to soccer practice? Sure can. We're having slow cooked ribs for dinner. It was awesome. And then it became a lot.
你的健康值得拥有这一切，如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，你可以尝试一下 BetterHelp。今天就访问 betterhelp.com slash office ladies，在你的第一个月享受九折优惠。我父母最近有很多闲暇时间。起初，这挺好的。嘿，妈妈，你能开车送我去足球训练吗？当然可以。我们晚餐吃慢烤排骨。太棒了。然后这就变得有点多了。
Some friends are coming over to watch a movie. Oh, what are we watching? I'll make some popcorn. Thanks to Voila, they can order all our fresh favorites from Sobeez, Farmboy, and Longos online, which is super reliable. And now my parents are reliable. A little too reliable. Voila, your groceries delivered, just like that.
有些朋友要过来一起看电影。哦，我们要看什么？我去做点爆米花。多亏了 Voila，他们可以在网上从 Sobeys、Farmboy 和 Longos 订购所有我们新鲜喜爱的食品，这超级可靠。现在我的父母也很可靠了。有点太可靠了。Voila，你的杂货送货上门，就是这么简单。
Well we are back and you guys we cannot do an episode about Stanley and not list some of his greatest shutdowns of his co-workers. There are many but I'm gonna highlight five. Okay number one and it might be the most popular of all of his shutdowns, you guys can probably all guess, but it's when he took down Ryan and take your daughter to work day. Stanley confronts Ryan about his teenage daughter. It's one of the most quoted Stanley lines from the show, and Leslie improvised quite a bit of it. That little girl is a child. I don't want to see you sniffing around her anymore this afternoon. Do you understand? Yes, sir. Boy, have you lost your mind because I'll help you find it. That little girl is a child. I don't want to see you sniffing around her anymore this
好了，我们回来了，伙计们，我们不能做一集关于斯坦利的节目却不列举一些他对他同事最经典的“闭嘴”时刻。有很多，但我将重点列出五个。好的，第一点，这也可能是他所有“闭嘴”时刻中最受欢迎的一个，你们大家大概都能猜到，那就是他在“带女儿上班日”对付瑞安（Ryan）的时候。斯坦利就他的十几岁女儿质问瑞安。这是剧中被引用最多的斯坦利台词之一，莱斯利即兴发挥了很多。那个小女孩还是个孩子。今天下午我不想再看到你在她身边晃悠了。你明白了吗？是的，先生。天哪，你疯了吗？因为我会帮你找回理智。那个小女孩还是个孩子。今天下午我不想再看到你在她身边晃悠了。
afternoon. Do you understand? Boy, have you lost your mind because I'll help you find it. What you're looking for? Ain't nobody going to help you out there. Jesus can come through that door and he's not going to help you if you don't stop sniffing after my child. Okay. Well, lady, I traded messages with Greg Daniels about this episode, and he said that is his favorite Stanley line, and he confirmed that Leslie improvised almost all of it I love it. That's Greg's favorite Stanley moment. Me too Number two on my shutdown list who can forget when Stanley completely shuts down Michael in the episode
你明白了吗？天哪，你疯了吗？因为我会帮你找回理智。你在找什么？外面的任何人都帮不了你。就算耶稣从那扇门走进来，如果你不停止纠缠我的孩子，他也帮不了你。好吧。好吧，女士，我曾就这一集与格雷格·丹尼尔斯互发过信息，他说那是他最喜欢的斯坦利台词，并且他证实莱斯利几乎即兴发挥了所有这些内容。我太喜欢了。那是格雷格最喜欢的斯坦利时刻。我也是。我“闭嘴”列表上的第二点，谁能忘得了斯坦利在
Did I stutter if you remember Michael has a conference room scene where he's trying to get everyone to energize the office, right? And he's holding this meeting and he asks Stanley to contribute. And he says, Stanley, hey, you want to help us out with that? Stanley earth to Stanley. And Stanley does not look up and he says, not me. And Michael goes, yes, you come on Stanley, put your little game down and join the group. And Stanley goes, no. And then Michael then Michael says Stanley we're having a little and Stanley says leave me alone
《我结巴了吗？》（Did I stutter）一集中彻底让迈克尔（Michael）闭嘴的情节？如果你还记得的话，迈克尔有一个会议室场景，他试图让所有人为办公室注入活力，对吧？他开着这个会，并要求斯坦利发言。他说：“斯坦利，嘿，你想帮我们解决一下这个问题吗？斯坦利，地球呼叫斯坦利。”而斯坦利头都没抬，说道：“不，我不想。”迈克尔接着说：“是的，来吧，斯坦利，放下你的小游戏，加入集体。”而斯坦利说：“不。”然后迈克尔迈克尔接着说：“斯坦利，我们正在开一个小……”而斯坦利说：“
damn it I mean could you imagine that happening in a conference room meeting like to your boss like I could not even imagine in that same episode they have a knockdown drag-out argument in bullpen, and he calls Michael a professional idiot. Well, this is crazy, lady. You didn't know this, but I also reached out to Phyllis about working with Leslie. You knew that part, right? Yeah. When I was trading messages with her, she said that was her favorite Stanley episode and moment, was watching Leslie go toe to toe with Steve Carell in those scenes. Wow.
别烦我，该死。”我是说，你能想象这种事发生在会议室的会议上吗？就像对你的老板那样——我简直无法想象。在同一集中，他们在办公区发生了激烈的争吵，他称迈克尔为一个“专业的白痴”。好吧，这太疯狂了，女士。你可能不知道这一点，但我还联系了菲利丝，询问关于与莱斯利合作的事。你知道那部分，对吧？对。当我与她互发信息时，她说那是她最喜欢的斯坦利剧集和时刻，就是看着莱斯利在那些场景中与史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）针锋相对。哇。
Well, he really did. He commanded the whole room. I mean, you could have heard a pin drop because his performance was so fantastic. Number three on my Stanley shutdown list is his famous rant about Christmas parties and Christmas wishes. He says, look, I've been here 18 years and have suffered through some weird thematic Christmases. A Honolulu Christmas, a Pulp Fiction Christmas, a Muslim Christmas, Moroccan Christmas, Mo-rockin Christmas. I don't want it! Christmas is Christmas is Christmas is
嗯，他真的做到了。他掌控了整个房间。我是说，你甚至可以听到针掉地上的声音，因为他的表演太精彩了。在我的斯坦利“闭嘴”列表上的第三点，是他关于圣诞派对和圣诞愿望的著名长篇大火。他说：“听着，我在这里待了18年，经受了一些奇奇怪怪主题的圣诞节。火奴鲁鲁圣诞节、低俗小说圣诞节、穆斯林圣诞节、摩洛哥圣诞节、摩-洛哥圣诞节。我不要！圣诞节就是圣诞节就是圣诞节就是
Christmas. Again, he shut down the whole conference room meeting. He just wanted playing Baby Jesus, lying in a manger Christmas. Yeah. Number four, sometimes you don't have to use words for a shutdown. You can just have one look that scares the crap out of everyone. For example, in the episode PDA, when Andy says to Aaron, don't look at Stanley, I accidentally did his Sudoku. And then it cuts to Stanley and if looksix could kill, he shut down Andy.
圣诞节。”同样，他让整个会议室的会议都闭嘴了。他只想过那种圣婴耶稣躺在马槽里的圣诞节。对。第四点，有时你不需要用言辞来让别人闭嘴。你只需一个能把所有人都吓得半死的眼神。例如，在《PDA》那一集中，当安迪（Andy）对艾琳（Erin）说：“别看斯坦利，我一不小心把他玩的数独给填了。”然后画面切到斯坦利，如果眼神能杀人的话，他已经让安迪彻底闭嘴了。
And then number five is one of my all-time favorites. It's how Stanley shuts down Dwight and his Shrootbucks in the episode The Job. Let's hear it. When rainfall occurs, does it usually fall in a liquid, solid, or gaseous state? Liquid. Very good. You have earned one Shrorewt buck. I don't want it. Then you have been deducted 50 shrewt bucks. Make it a hundred. Don't you want to earn shrewt bucks? No. In fact, I'll give you a billion Stanley Nichols if you never talk to me again. What's
然后第五点是我个人最喜欢的之一。那是斯坦利在《工作》（The Job）一集中如何让德怀特（Dwight）以及他的“舒特币”（Shrootbucks）闭嘴。我们来听听。当降水发生时，它通常是以液体、固体还是气态形式落下？液体。很好。你赚了一个舒特币。我不要。那你被扣除了50个舒特币。凑个整，扣一百。你难道不想赚取舒特币吗？不想。事实上，如果你再也不跟我说话，我会给你十亿斯坦利尼克尔（Stanley Nickels）。
the ratio of Stanley Nichols to shrewt bucks? same as the ratio of unicorns to leprechauns. But I like how he says, don't ever talk to me again. Anyway, the Stanley shutdowns are an absolute delight. I had a lot of fun rewatching them and Leslie just, he just is so fantastic in each moment. You know, I don't think there are any, and correct me if I'm wrong, Angela, since you clearly deep dived the Stanley shutdowns. I don't think there's like a Stanley Pam shutdown or even really a Stanley Angela one. He really would focus on Michael Ryan, I think then Andy, because Andy was in his desk clump. Dwight, he thought Dwight was an idiot. Dwight, yeah. Yeah, he kind of left the ladies alone. I
斯坦利尼克尔和舒特币的汇率是多少？就像独角兽和妖精的比例一样。但我喜欢他说“永远别跟我说话”的那种语气。无论如何，斯坦利的“闭嘴”时刻绝对是一大享受。我重新观看它们时获得了许多乐趣，而且莱斯利在每一个时刻都表现得如此出色。你知道，我认为没有——如果我弄错了请纠正我，安吉拉，既然你显然深入研究了斯坦利的“闭嘴”时刻。我认为没有什么“斯坦利对帕姆闭嘴”的时刻，甚至也没有什么“斯坦利对安吉拉”的时刻。他真的只会把焦点放在迈克尔、瑞安身上，我想然后是安迪，因为安迪和他在同一组办公桌。德怀特，他觉得德怀特是个白痴。德怀特，对。是的。他基本上把女士们留在一边。我
mean, you know, him and Phyllis have their thing. We'll get to it. Yeah. We also got this fan question from Bree S. in Indiana. Her favorite Stanley moment was also when he shuts down Ryan and says, boy have you lost your mind because I'll help you find it. And you know what, Bree, I thought we should all share our favorite Stanley clips too. Jenna, why don't you go first? All right. Well, my favorite Stanley line is in season two, Boys and Girls. This is a deep cut. It's just a personal fave that really speaks to me. I feel Stanley in this moment. This is when Jim, Ryan, and Stanley are all down in the warehouse
是说，你知道的，他和菲利丝有他们之间的互动。我们稍后会讲到。对。我们还收到了来自印第安纳州的布里·S（Bree S.）的粉丝提问。她最喜欢的斯坦利时刻也是当他让瑞安闭嘴并说：“天哪，你疯了吗？因为我会帮你找回理智。”你知道吗，布里，我觉得我们也应该分享我们最喜欢的斯坦利片段。珍娜，你先来吧？好的。嗯，我最喜欢的斯坦利台词是在第二季的《男孩与女孩》（Boys and Girls）中。这是一个冷门桥段。这只是一个真正触动我的个人最爱。我在这个时刻感同身受。这是当吉姆、瑞安和斯坦利都在仓库里
and they have to unload a truck together. You know what? We could get this done a lot quicker if we formed a type of assembly line. This here is a run out the plot situation. Just like upstairs. I just love it. Run out the clock.
而且他们必须一起卸货的时候。你知道吗？如果我们组成某种流水线，我们能把这干得快得多。这纯粹是个“消磨时间”的情况。就像楼上一样。我太喜欢了。消磨时间。
Speaking of shutdown, he's like, I'm gonna shut this down right here. Yeah. We're not organized. This is a run out the clock situation. We don't need to chat. Let's just get it done. Yeah.
说到让别人闭嘴，他的态度就像是：我要把这事立刻打住。对。我们没有组织好。这是一个消磨时间的情况。我们不需要闲聊。赶紧把它干完吧。对。
Sam, what about you? Mine is a John Pretzel day when someone tries to cut in line. Phyllis. Yes. Yeah. I wanna kill you. Hey, hey, hey, Phyllis, what are you doing? I'm just saying hi to Bob.
萨姆，你呢？我最喜欢的是在椒盐卷饼日，当有人试图插队的时候。菲利丝。对。是的。我想杀了你。嘿，嘿，嘿，菲利丝，你在干什么？我只是在跟鲍勃打招呼。
No, I think you're cutting in line. Well settle down, Scott. I'm not going to settle down. No way. Get in the back, please. Boo. Boo. Back out of line.
不，我觉得你在插队。好吧，冷静点，斯科特。我不会冷静下来的。没门。请到后面去。嘘。嘘。回到队伍后面去。
Thank you. He's so quick to boo Phyllis. Yeah, something about the way he boos is so funny. Yeah. Cassie, what about you? So Stanley's my favorite office character, because I think if I worked at Dunder Mifflin, I would be most like Stanley.
谢谢。他嘘菲利丝的动作好快。对，他嘘人的那个方式有种说不出的搞笑。对。凯茜，你呢？所以斯坦利是我最喜欢的办公室角色，因为我觉得如果我在邓德米夫林工作，我最像斯坦利。
Oh my goodness, Cassie. Love that. So my favorite clip is also a little bit of a deep cut. It's in Night Out when Jim and Pam lock everybody inside the parking lot, and he says this to them. Did you not tell the security guard we were working late? No. I didn't. But let's go inside and I can call him right now.
哦天哪，凯茜。太喜欢这个了。所以我最喜欢的片段也算是一个小冷门。它在《夜出》（Night Out）中，当时吉姆和帕姆把所有人锁在停车场里面，他对他们说了这样一番话。你没有告诉保安我们要加班吗？没有。我没有。但我们可以进去，我现在就给他打电话。
We can't. I locked the office from the inside when we left. Perfect. You guys work together on this one. If I'm not in my bath with a glass of red wine in one hour, you're both dead. I guess there's the Pam shut down I was wondering about. in my bath with a glass of red wine in one hour, you're both dead. I guess there's the Pam shut down. I was wondering about it. Yeah, Pam got looped in with Jim, but yeah. Well, mine is from Jury Duty because I, I love Jury Duty and Stanley looks so forward to it. Let's hear it. Do they bring in food or do you get to go out? No, they bring it in.
我们不能。我们离开时我从里面把办公室的锁锁上了。完美。你们俩在这件事上配合得真好。如果我没在一小时内泡着澡喝上一杯红葡萄酒，你们两个就死定了。我想这就是我一直纳闷的“帕姆闭嘴”时刻了。在一小时内泡着澡喝上一杯红葡萄酒，你们两个就死定了。我想这就是“帕姆闭嘴”时刻了。我之前还纳闷来着。对，帕姆跟吉姆一起被连累了，不过是的。好吧，我最喜欢的那段来自《陪审团义务》（Jury Duty），因为我——我太爱陪审团义务了，而且斯坦利对它充满期待。我们来听听。他们会提供食物还是你可以出去？不，他们会把食物带进来。
You lucky son of a bitch. Do they bring in food or do you get to go out? No, they bring it in. You lucky son of a bitch. I have been trying to get on jury duty every single year since I was 18 years old. To get to go sit in an air conditioned room downtown, judging people, why my lunch is paid for. That is the life. I just laugh so hard when he says, you lucky son of a bitch, that you got jury duty. The thing that people try to avoid. And I get excited for jury duty.
你这个幸运的混蛋。他们会提供食物还是你可以出去？不，他们会把食物带进来。你这个幸运的混蛋。我从18岁起就一直在尝试每年都去当陪审团成员。能去市中心一间有空调的房间里坐着，对别人评头论足，同时我的午餐还有人报销。那才是生活啊。当他说“你这个幸运的混蛋，你被选去当陪审团了”时，我真的笑得前仰后合。那是人们极力想要避免的事情。而我却对陪审团义务感到兴奋。
I have my notepad. I'm ready to take notes. I'm very excited about it. I love to people watch, observe. Maybe I judge, I don't know. I would love to be on a jury for maybe like a non-criminal trial. Yes. I got almost chosen for a criminal trial and it was after like the office and the fame
我有我的记事本。我已经准备好做笔记了。我对此感到非常兴奋。我喜欢观察人、进行观察。也许我会在心里评判，我不知道。我很乐意去参加一个陪审团，也许是像那种非刑事审判的。是的。我差点被选为一个刑事审判的陪审员，那是在《办公室》播出之后以及由于《办公室》带来的名气
of the office and I felt very vulnerable. I was like, I'm not anonymous on this jury and whoever this person did their crime with who might want to shut me down or intimidate me, like I'm kind of a sitting duck. A little bit, yeah. I ended up getting excused. I was relieved. I got excused. My most recent one was a fraud case.
之后，我感到非常脆弱。我想，在这个陪审团里我不是匿名的，无论这个人是和谁一起犯罪的，他们可能会想要让我闭嘴或者恐吓我，就像我有点像个活靶子。有点像，是的。我最后被批准退出了。我松了一口气。我被批准退出了。我最近的一次是一个诈骗案。
I would love a fraud case. I know. I was very excited about it. Oh, I hate fraud. I know. I was so excited to be on the jury. And then one of my fellow jurymen asked me for a selfie photo. They were a big office fan and the judge saw it and I got booted.
我很想碰上一个诈骗案。我知道。我当时对此感到非常兴奋。哦，我讨厌诈骗。我知道。我能加入陪审团感到无比兴奋。然后我的一个陪审团同伴向我要了一张自拍照。他们是一个狂热的办公室粉丝，法官看到了，然后我就被踢出去了。
I didn't take the picture! I want to know what would happen if scam goddess was called for jury duty on a fraud trial. She would get dismissed because she has so much knowledge. Right? Yeah. Yeah. Mm-hmm. I love a fraud. I know. I was really excited. I mean, I hate fraud, but I love to hear about a fraud. I know. There was a whole, I guess a whole, like, what do you call it? They had a whole, what do you call it, lady? I mean, I literally have no idea. What do you call what? They had created a whole like, Powerpoint?
我根本没拍照！我很想知道，如果“诈骗女神”（Scam Goddess）被传唤去审理一个诈骗案的陪审团，会发生什么。她会因为懂得太多而被驳回。对吧？对。对。嗯哼。我喜欢诈骗案。我知道。我当时真的很兴奋。我是说，我讨厌诈骗，但我喜欢听关于诈骗的故事。我知道。有一个完整的，我猜整个——你管那叫什么来着？他们整个——你管那叫什么，女士？我是说，我真的毫无头绪。你管什么叫什么？他们创建了一个完整的，像，PowerPoint？
Faking network of things and how they got money and it was like, Oh, your case. Yes, I looked it up after it was, I mean, they were clever. But anyway, you know what I am realizing right now as we talk about how much I love fraud, But anyway, you know what I am realizing right now as we talk about how much I love fraud and then also hate fraud is that I love movies where that, what do you call it? Like con artists movies.
伪造的网络和他们如何弄到钱的，而且就像，哦，你的案子。是的，我在事后查了一下，我是说，他们确实很聪明。不过话说回来，我此刻在谈论我们如何热爱诈骗时意识到的一点是——但话说回来，我此刻在谈论我们如何热爱诈骗以及同时也讨厌诈骗时意识到的一点是，我喜欢那种——你管那叫什么——骗子电影。
Yes, like the grifters or the sting. I just watched, what's someone where the house of games. Oh yeah, what's that one? Catch Me If You Can? Oh, yes! Right? And it's like, love a con artist movie. Right.
是的，就像《骗中骗》（The Sting）或者类似这样的。我刚看了，叫什么来着，那个关于《游戏屋》（House of Games）的。哦，对，那是哪个？《猫鼠游戏》（Catch Me If You Can）？哦，对！对吧？就像，超爱骗子电影。对。
What do we love about con artists? I think it's because I think I see through the con and I'm like, how are they, I mean, come on, how do people see this? And then I'd probably be conned. Right. Anyway. Okay, where were we?
我们究竟喜欢骗子电影的什么？我想这是因为我觉得我看穿了骗局，然后我想，他们是怎么——我是说，拜托，人们怎么会看不出来呢？然后我可能就会被骗。好吧。总之，我们刚才讲到哪儿了？
Well, anyway, I love that about Jury Duty and Stanley being so excited and wanting to be on it. Is it time for my area of interest? Yes. Oh, I'm excited. Well, I really wanted to dig into the origin of Stanley Hudson. I always find that stuff interesting. Yeah. So, I started by reaching out to Greg Daniels about how he chose the name Stanley Hudson. Because Greg always seems to have a fun story about how he chose the names for our show.
总之，我太喜欢《陪审团义务》里斯坦利的那种兴奋和想要加入的心情了。现在是我感兴趣的领域的时间吗？是的。哦，我很兴奋。好吧，我真的很想深入挖掘斯坦利·哈德森的起源。我总是觉得这些东西很有趣。是的。所以，我首先联系了格雷格·丹尼尔斯，询问他是如何选择“斯坦利·哈德森”这个名字的。因为格雷格似乎总是有一些有趣的故事，关于他是如何为我们的节目选择名字的。
They're some of my favorite Greg tidbits. This did not disappoint. OK, let's hear it. Greg said, my memory is I called the character Stanley Hudson because I wanted a strong, no-nonsense energy that reminded me a bit of my father-in-law, Stanley H. Lieberstein. Yes. And in parentheses, he wrote Paul's dad and Warren's dad. Yes. Yes. So how cool. Well, I loved it then when Greg was writing Stanley, he had a vision of a person in
它们是我最喜欢的格雷格趣闻之一。这没有让人失望。好吧，我们来听听。格雷格说：“我的记忆是，我把这个角色命名为斯坦利·哈德森，是因为我想要一种强烈的、不废话的能量，这让我想起了我的一位岳父，斯坦利·H·利伯斯坦（Stanley H. Lieberstein）。”是的。并且在括号里，他写了“保罗的爸爸和沃伦的爸爸”。是的。是的。所以多酷啊。好吧，我当时很喜欢的是，当格雷格在写斯坦利的时候，他心里有一个人物的愿景。
mind. You know, it's like you had an energy in mind And then it kind of helps you drive that character specificity. I loved it I also reached out to Allison Jones about Leslie's audition because I know that with a lot of the supporting cast There wasn't really a template for the character or even a big character description. You guys really kind of created your roles in many ways So, you know how in our pilot episode, we were using the script from the BBC office? Yes. Well, they had a character on their show named Malcolm. Yeah.
你知道，这就好像你心里有一种能量。然后它有点助于推动该角色的独特性。我很喜欢。我还联系了艾莉森·琼斯（Allison Jones），询问关于莱斯利试镜的事，因为我知道对于许多配角来说，并没有真正的角色模板，甚至没有很大的角色描述。你们在很多方面真的是自己塑造了各自的角色。所以，你知道的，在我们的试播集里，我们使用的是英国BBC版《办公室》的剧本。是的。好吧，他们在他们的节目里有一个名叫马尔科姆（Malcolm）的角色。对。
He was kind of an older grumpy white man with glasses. And they gave several of Malcolm's lines to the character of Stanley. Right. But that's it. Like the rest of the character is really Leslie's doing, I think. Right. Allison confirmed that they had a pretty wide open call for the role. They read people of all ethnicities. And she said she did not know Leslie before he came in to read for Stanley, but she knew right away that she needed to bring him to meet the producers because he just nailed it.
他是个有点年纪的老脾气暴躁白人，戴着眼镜。他们把马尔科姆的好几句台词分给了斯坦利这个角色。对。但仅此而已。就像角色的其余部分真的是莱斯利的功劳，我认为。对。艾莉森证实，他们为这个角色进行了相当开放的公开招募。他们试镜了各种族的人。并且她说在莱斯利进来为斯坦利试读之前她并不认识他，但她一眼就看出她需要带他去见制片人，因为他简直表现得完美无瑕。
And then Angela, you sent me, you found his audition tape online. Yeah. Should we listen to it? Because it's really fun. You can actually hear Alison Jones reading with him. Yeah. She's playing Michael Scott.
然后安吉拉，你发给我了——你在网上找到了他的试镜磁带。对。我们应该听听看吗？因为真的很有趣。你实际上可以听到艾莉森·琼斯在和他对戏。对。她在扮演迈克尔·斯科特。
Here it is. I said, if Corporal wants to come here and interfere, you may mess with my children, I am if anyone's going to. Yeah, but Michael, what if they do downsize here? Not gonna happen. It could be out of your hands, Michael. That was it. Those were the two lines. It could be out of your hands, Michael. Yeah, and those were the two lines from the British pilot also.
给你。我说，如果中士想来这里插手，你可以惹我的孩子，如果要惹的话我是。是啊，迈克尔，万一他们这里要缩减规模呢？不会发生这种事的。这可能由不得你做主，迈克尔。就是这样。就这两句台词。这可能由不得你做主，迈克尔。对，这也是那个英国飞行员的两句台词。
Yeah. Crazy. But you can already hear the character. I can already hear it even in those two lines from the British pilot also. Yeah. Crazy. But you can already hear the character. I can already hear it even in those two lines. Oh, he's fully formed. Yeah. In his audition tape. It's really crazy.
对。太疯狂了。但你已经能听出那个角色了。甚至从英国飞行员的那两句台词里我也能听出来。对。太疯狂了。但你已经能听出那个角色了。甚至从那两句台词里我也能听出来。哦，他已经完全成形了。对。在他的试镜磁带里。真的很疯狂。
And I've also been trading messages just in general with Terry Weinberg. She was one of our producers from the very beginning. We love Terry. Love. That's someone who I want to chat with. Oh, I would love to hear from Terry. Yeah. Well, she was asking me, what are you guys doing on the podcast?
而且我平时也一直在和特里·温伯格发信息。她是我们最初的制作人之一。我们很爱特里。爱。那是我想聊聊的人。哦，我很想听听特里的消息。对。嗯，她问我，你们在播客里做什么呢？
I said, oh, we're about to do all about Stanley Hudson. And she said, oh my gosh, I remember his audition. Here's what she said. I think he was kind of having a day by the time he got into the room, like traffic or heat. He had a bit of an attitude, which must have worked well because the audition was fantastic. And I don't know if you all remember when Angela interviewed Leslie for our Stair Maggeddon episode, he shared his side of the audition experience. Yeah, that is so funny
我说，哦，我们正准备做关于斯坦利·哈德森的一切。她说，哦天哪，我记得他的试镜。她是这么说的。我想他去到面试房间的时候那天心情可能有点不太好，比如遇到了交通堵塞或者天气太热。他有点态度，这效果一定不错，因为试镜太棒了。我不知道大家是否还记得安吉拉在我们的“楼梯末日”那一集里采访莱斯利时，他分享了自己对试镜经历的看法。对，太搞笑了
hearing what Terry saw. I know. It was very true of what was happening in his life at the moment. Leslie's interview is really fun. If you guys missed it, you can find it in our Stairmageddon breakdown. But I thought we should hear what he had to say about the day he auditioned. Here it is. I got my job on The Office. Uh, Alison Jones called me in and said that she wanted me to audition for a show called The Office based upon the British version.
听听特里看到了什么。我知道。这很符合他当时的生活状态。莱斯利的采访真的很有趣。如果大家错过了，可以在我们的“楼梯末日”解析中找到。但我想我们应该听听他对试镜那天有什么话说。给你。我在《办公室》里得到了我的工作。呃，艾莉森·琼斯打电话叫我去，说她想让我为一部根据英国版改编的名为《办公室》的剧集试镜。
I had never watched it but heard it was successful. Went to the first audition, had on a very nice press shirt suit tie, was looking very elegant and dapper. Did the audition, she told me, said, okay, I want you to go to the callback but when you go to the callback, don't go in looking as crisp and pressed as you are. You want to come in looking kind of sloppy and kind of you know sure wrinkled to shovel because you are at this paper company and you've been there for quite a time and you really don't want to be there so I went to the audition got to the callback audition I had another audition that day
我从来没看过，但听说很成功。去了第一次试镜，穿了一件非常漂亮的熨烫衬衫西装领带，看起来非常优雅绅士。试镜完了，她告诉我，说，好的，我希望你去复试，但你去复试的时候，不要穿得像现在这样笔挺熨帖。你要穿得有点邋遢，有点，你知道的，皱巴巴、衣衫褴褛，因为你在这家纸业公司工作，你已经在那里待了很长时间了，你真的不想呆在那里，所以我去了试镜，到了复试试镜，那天我还有另一个试镜
for another project and when I got to the officeback audition. I had another audition that day for another project. And when I got to the office audition, there were about 50, 75 people there. It was a very crowded room. And I looked and I thought, so wait a minute, all these people are ahead of me. I have time to go to my other audition. Hopped in the car, left, went to the other audition. On the way back, ran into a lot of traffic and ambulances and school buses and every senior citizen in the free world out driving. So when I got back, I got to sit down
为另一个项目，当我到达办公室时……复试。那天我还有另一个项目要试镜。当我到达《办公室》试镜现场时，大概有50、75个人在那里。房间里挤满了人。我看了看，心想，等一下，所有这些人都在我前面。我有时间去参加另一个试镜。跳进车里，离开，去了另一个试镜。在回来的路上，遇到了很多交通堵塞、救护车、校车以及自由世界上所有开车的退休老人。所以当我回来的时候，我坐下来
and do my reading with Phyllis Smith. Alison Jones said, oh Leslie, thank you so much for being patient and waiting. They said you were in the restroom. And I just went, oh yeah, okay. No, my pleasure. I didn't mind waiting at all. And sat down, read with Phyllis. Greg Daniels told us when you finish the scene on the paper, just keep going. He wanted us to do some improv, so I did. So I incorporated what I had just gone through driving through rush hour traffic with Phyllis and Phyllis was feeding me all the you know good vibes that she was feeding me and we bantered back and forth and we looked up and the people at the casting table were laughing and you know cut me off said okay thank you and I went outside Allison gave me two thumbs
和菲利斯·史密斯一起对词。艾莉森·琼斯说，哦，莱斯利，非常感谢你的耐心等待。他们说你在洗手间。我当时就说，哦，好吧，没问题。不，这是我的荣幸。我一点也不介意等。然后坐下来，和菲利斯对词。格雷格·丹尼尔斯告诉我们，当你在纸上完成这个场景时，继续演下去。他想让我们做一些即兴表演，所以我照做了。所以我把刚才开车穿过上下班高峰期的经历结合到了和菲利斯的对手戏中，菲利斯一直在给我那些，你知道的，她给我的良好氛围，我们一来一回地开玩笑，我们抬头一看，选角桌后面的人都在笑，然后，你知道的，打断了我，说，好的，谢谢，然后我走出去，艾莉森对我竖起了两个大拇指
up and I thought you know okay she's just a sweet, loving, positive person and I probably won't hear anything. A few weeks later I got a call and next thing I knew they said, you booked it. I mean, I just think it's so funny. Like Terry's little memory just being like, I feel like he was annoyed that day, but it really worked. Maybe traffic, the heat, it was all of those things. All of those things. He was Stanley the minute he walked in that room. I love that and I love hearing Leslie tell his story. You know, Leslie was one of the very first people from the extended cast
我心想，你知道的，好吧，她只是一个甜美、有爱心、积极的人，我可能不会听到任何消息。几周后我接到一个电话，接下来我知道的时候他们说，你被选上了。我是觉得太搞笑了。就像特里的那个小记忆一样，就觉得，我觉得他那天很不高兴，但真的很管用。也许是交通，是天气，所有这些因素。所有这些因素。他一走进那个房间就是斯坦利。我喜欢这样，也喜欢听莱斯利讲述他的故事。你知道的，莱斯利是扩展演员阵容中最早的人之一
that I met on the first day that I showed up to shoot the pilot. I met on the first day that I showed up to shoot the pilot. So I had done a table read with Steve, John, Rain, BJ, and David Dunman and Phyllis. And other people read all of our roles. We weren't there. Yeah, I remember that. This was like a very early table read that I believe we did for Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant for any maybe little notes that they had. And they were still closing our contracts and everything, so we couldn't go to that
我第一天去拍试播集时遇到的。我第一天去拍试播集时遇到的。所以我之前和史蒂夫、约翰、雷恩、B.J.、大卫·丹曼还有菲利斯一起读过剧本。其他人读了我们所有的角色。我们当时不在场。对，我记得。这是一次很早的剧本围读，我想那是我们为瑞奇·热维斯和斯蒂芬·莫昌特准备的，可能为了他们提出的一些小意见。而且他们当时还在敲定我们的合同之类的事情，所以我们不能去那个
table read. Yes. So anyway, when I was walking into my first day of the pilot episode, I was meeting you and Oscar and Leslie and Brian all for the first time. But Leslie was, and I have such a strong memory of meeting him because he was so like friendly and like had a whole personality because you know how he is. Yeah. In real life.
剧本围读会。是的。所以无论如何，当我走进试播集的第一天时，我是第一次见到你、奥斯卡、莱斯利和布莱恩。但莱斯利——我对见他有着非常深刻的记忆，因为他非常友好，而且很有个性，你知道他是怎样的。是的。在现实生活中。
Yes, in real life. Yeah. And chatting, hair and makeup and all that. And then when he became Stanley, I was like, oh my gosh, he's like a different person. It was, it was very, very funny to me. He smiles a lot more in real life, you guys. He does, and he's thoughtful. He's like the person that's like,
是的，在现实生活中。对。还在发型化妆间聊了天之类的。然后当他变成斯坦利时，我想，哦天哪，他就像变了一个人。这对我来说非常非常搞笑。你们看，他在现实生活中笑得更多。他确实如此，而且他很体贴。他就是那种会说，
oh, Angela, I know you like tea in the morning, and he would get you a cup of tea. He's that person. He's also the kind of person where if there's only a few chairs and he sees a lady come by, he stands up and gives his chair to her. Yes. He's that person. He is. And I have to tell you, I was cold so many times in those early mornings. I can't even tell you how many times Leslie would give me his suit jacket if I was cold. Yeah. Sweetheart. Well, listen, we also got a lot of questions about Stanley's family.
哦，安吉拉，我知道你早上喜欢喝茶，他会为你泡一杯茶。他就是那种人。他也是那种如果只有几把椅子而他看到有女士走过来，就会站起来把座位让给对方的人。是的。他就是那种人。他是。而且我得告诉你们，在那些清晨，我冷过很多次。我甚至无法形容有多少次，如果我冷了，莱斯利会把他的西装外套脱下来给我穿。是的。真是个甜心。好吧，听着，我们还收到了很多关于斯坦利家庭的问题。
Because it is a little bit of a hot mess. And I want to preface this by saying, I don't think I got any answers. But we got so much mail about it that I wanted to at least address it. So fan question from Martina B in Denver and Kendall W in Phoenix, Arizona. How many kids does Stanley have? The slight inconsistencies bother me, so I'm hoping you ladies can help. In season two, episode five, Halloween,
因为这确实有点一团糟。我想在前面加一句，我觉得我没有得到任何答案。但我们收到了太多关于这方面的信件，所以我想至少应该回应一下。因此，来自丹佛的玛蒂娜·B和亚利桑那州凤凰城的肯德尔·W提出了一个粉丝问题。斯坦利有几个孩子？这些轻微的前后矛盾让我很困扰，所以我希望你们这些女士能帮帮忙。在第二季第五集《万圣节》中，
Stanley says, I have kids in college, kids, plural. Valentine's Day, season two, episode 16. In Michael's video presentation, he says, this is Stanley Hudson, one of our talented salesmen, an African-American father of two. In Take Your Daughter to Work Day, season two, episode 18, we meet Stanley's daughter, Melissa.
斯坦利说，我有上大学的孩子，孩子们（复数）。情人节，第二季第十六集。在迈克尔的视频演示中，他说，这是斯坦利·哈德森，我们才华横溢的销售员之一，一个有两名孩子的非裔美国父亲。在“带女儿上班日”第二季第十八集里，我们见到了斯坦利的女儿梅丽莎。
But Melissa is in eighth grade. So does Stanley have two kids in college and Melissa? Is Melissa his third kid? How many kids does Stanley have? Well, here's what I could piece together. In sexual harassment season two, he has a photo of one daughter on his desk and we know she goes to Catholic girls school. Yeah. And I assume that this is the same daughter that he brings to work and take your daughter to work day. Her name is Melissa. And we also find out she is Stanley's daughter
但梅丽莎在上八年级。所以斯坦利有两个上大学的孩子和一个梅丽莎？梅丽莎是他的第三个孩子吗？斯坦利到底有几个孩子？好吧，以下是我拼凑出来的信息。在第二季的《性骚扰》中，他的办公桌上放着一个女儿的照片，我们知道她上的是女子天主教学校。对，我猜这就是他带去上班并参加“带女儿上班日”的同一个女儿。她的名字叫梅丽莎。我们还发现她是斯坦利
from his first marriage because she says, Terry is my stepmom. But beyond that, there are no details about additional children. However, for what it's worth, Wikipedia says Stanley has two children. I think the thing that's tripping us up is in Halloween when he says,
前妻的女儿，因为她说特丽是我的继母。但除此之外，关于其他孩子没有任何细节。不过，不管有没有用，维基百科说斯坦利有两个孩子。我觉得让我们纠结的是他在《万圣节》里说的那句，
I have kids in college. Yeah. I think he has two kids from his first marriage. One is in college. One is Melissa. I'm going to give it to Stanley that he's the kind of person that just, you know how he is about having to pay for things. And he's just like, I've got kids in college. You know, he's going to have another kid in college. Yeah, college is looming. Yes. For Melissa. He's already got one in college.
我有上大学的孩子。对。我想他前妻有两个孩子。一个是上大学的。一个是梅丽莎。我觉得斯坦利就是那种人，你知道他对待花钱的态度，他就会说，我有上大学的孩子。你知道的，他很快又会有一个上大学的孩子。对，大学近在眼前了。是的，为了梅丽莎。他已经有一个上大学的了。
Yeah. I think he has two kids, period. Two kids. Yeah. Okay, that's what I thought as well. There's nothing in the show Bible about it because the show Bible just says what he's said. Yeah. You know? Fans were also confused about Stanley's very complicated love life. Nothing in the show Bible about it because the show Bible just says what he's said. Yeah.
对。我觉得他总共就有两个孩子。两个孩子。对，好吧，我也是这么想的。剧本圣经（Show Bible）里没有关于这个的内容，因为剧本圣经只记录了他说过的话。对。你知道吗？粉丝们对斯坦利极其复杂的感情生活也感到很困惑。剧本圣经里没有关于这个的内容，因为剧本圣经只记录了他说过的话。对。
You know? Fans were also confused about Stanley's very complicated love life. Oh, it's spicy. So I'm going to break it down. We know he has an ex-wife and a current wife, Terry. In season six, we find out he's having an affair with Cynthia, his physical rehab nurse. And they end up knowing about one another because Michael accidentally tells Terry about Cynthia.
你知道吗？粉丝们对斯坦利极其复杂的感情生活也感到很困惑。哦，这太劲爆了。所以我来梳理一下。我们知道他有一个前妻和一个现任妻子特丽。在第六季中，我们发现他和他的物理康复护士辛西娅有了外遇。最后他们互相知道了对方的存在，因为迈克尔不小心把辛西娅的事告诉了特丽。
Yeah. And then for a while he's just with both of them. He has a wife and a girlfriend. I almost included that in my Stanley shutdown is when he bashed all the windows out of Michael's car. Sorry. Well, then in Stereomageddon, it is revealed that Stanley is having another affair with a woman named Lydia, who neither Cynthia nor Terry know about.
对，然后有一段时间他同时和这两个人在一起。他有一个妻子和一个女朋友。我差点把这个算进我的“斯坦利痛击事件”里，就是他把迈克尔车的所有车窗都砸碎的时候。抱歉。嗯，然后在“楼梯末日”里，曝光了斯坦利和另一个名叫莉迪亚的女人有了婚外情，辛西娅和特丽都不知道这个人。
So now he's in three relationships at once. And of course, there are also some questions as to whether or not Stanley also had an affair with Phyllis at any point. But Angela, I know you're going to address that a little later in the pod. I am. I'm mom detective that one. Oh. Oh.
所以现在他同时维持着三段关系。当然，也有人质疑斯坦利是否在某个时候和菲利斯也有过婚外情。但安吉拉，我知道你稍后会在播客里谈到这个。是的。我要当侦探去查清那个。哦。哦。
Well, that's all I got. I hope I was able to provide some new Stanley origin tidbits for you. I love it all listed out. I love sort of seeing the character as they unfolded on the show in the showbible list. I enjoy it. Well, why don't we take a break and when we come back, we will get to our fan mail Q and A section for all about Stanley Hudson. Let's do it. I have some really great clips coming up that I can't wait to share. Hint, hint, Phyllis and Stanley. The all-new all-electric Can-Am Pulse motorcycle is your cheat code for the city. Light, agile, and stylish for all you smart commuters.
好吧，我掌握的就这些。希望我能为大家提供一些关于斯坦利身世的新八卦。我喜欢把它们全部列出来。我喜欢在剧本圣经的列表中看到角色在剧中的展开方式。我很享受。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来，我们将进入关于斯坦利·哈德森的粉丝邮件问答环节。我们开始吧。我有一些非常棒的精彩片段要播出来，我已经迫不及待想和大家分享了。提示，提示，菲利斯和斯坦利。全新的纯电动Can-Am Pulse摩托车是你在城市穿梭的秘籍。轻巧、灵活、时尚，专为所有聪明的通勤族打造。
Find your Pulse today. Learn more at CanAmMotorcycles.com. Do you eat food? Do you go anywhere? Do you stream stuff? Well then, get the RBC ION Plus Visa and earn 3 times the points at grocery stores and restaurants as well as on gas, EV charging, daily transit, streaming services, digital gaming and more. All the time. Get the RBC Ion Plus Visa.
今天就找到你的Pulse。访问 CanAmMotorcycles.com 了解更多信息。你吃东西吗？你去任何地方吗？你刷剧吗？那么，办一张 RBC ION Plus Visa 卡，在杂货店、餐馆以及加油、电动汽车充电、日常交通、流媒体服务、数字游戏等方面赚取 3 倍积分。随时如此。获取 RBC Ion Plus Visa 卡。
Conditions apply. Visit rbc.com slash Ion Cards. All right, we are back and thank you so much for writing in with all your questions. We'd hope to have Leslie on today for our Q&A section. Angela, you reached out and he was unavailable to come on the pod, but between Angela's conversation with him and some other folks we reached out to, we were able to get answers to a lot of your awesome questions. Okay, let's start off with a fan mail flurry all about Pretzel Day. This one came in from Abby W in Charlotte, North Carolina, Amber R. from Charleston, South Carolina.
适用相关条款。请访问 rbc.com slash Ion Cards。好的，我们回来了，非常感谢大家写信提出所有这些问题。我们本来希望莱斯利今天能来参加我们的问答环节。安吉拉，你联系了他，但他没空来播客，但通过安吉拉与他的对话以及我们联系的其他一些人，我们得以解答了你们许多精彩的问题。好的，让我们从一个关于“百吉饼日”（Pretzel Day，注：此处原意为椒盐卷饼日，但翻译习惯常为椒盐脆饼）的粉丝邮件狂潮开始。这封信来自北卡罗来纳州夏洛特的艾比·W，南卡罗来纳州查尔斯顿的安博·R。
Angela S. from Ohio and Haley S. from Nashville, Tennessee. Everyone wants to know, what is Stanley's pretzel order? Yeah, people are really curious about this. When I saw all of this mail, I thought, do we not know Stanley's pretzel order? He loves Pretzel Day. He stands in line. Right. Okay. I watched it. The episode is the initiation, season three, episode five. Sure enough, after standing in line with Michael at nine minutes and 42 seconds, you see Stanley and Michael finally get to the front of the line, but the scene opens with Stanley getting his pretzel and walking away, just as Michael walks up and asks for his pretzel with the works.
来自俄亥俄州的安吉拉·S和来自田纳西州纳什维尔的海莉·S。每个人都想知道，斯坦利点的是什么口味的椒盐卷饼？对，大家对此非常好奇。当我看到所有这些邮件时，我想，我们难道不知道斯坦利点的什么椒盐卷饼吗？他太爱“椒盐卷饼日”了。他排着队。没错。好吧。我看了。那一集是《入职培训》（The Initiation），第三季第五集。果不其然，在和迈克尔一起排队9分42秒后，你看到斯坦利和迈克尔终于走到了队伍的最前面，但镜头开始时是斯坦利拿到他的椒盐卷饼然后走开，正好赶上迈克尔走过来要他的“全加料”椒盐卷饼。
You never find out what Stanley's pretzel was. So wait, I go to the Peacock superfan episode. I'm like, they must, it must be there. No, I didn't give up. I feel like I have a memory of them eating them. Oh, you're correct. I'll get to that. Okay. But that moment still does not reveal what was on his pretzel. Okay. However, everyone, fan mail flurry, I now became obsessed with this. I'm gonna tell you I have the answer. Okay. I Went to the shooting draft. I
你永远不知道斯坦利买的是什么椒盐卷饼。等等，我去看孔雀网（Peacock）的超级粉丝版。我想，他们一定有，一定在那里面。不，我没有放弃。我觉得我有他们吃椒盐卷饼的记忆。哦，你没记错。我会讲到那里的。好的。但那一刻仍然没有透露他的椒盐卷饼上有什么。不过，各位，粉丝邮件狂潮，我现在对此着迷了。我要告诉大家，我有答案了。好的。我找到了拍摄剧本。我
Love it in the shooting draft Stanley had a line where he orders his pretzel and Here's what he said one salty, please extra mustard There it is. Oh my gosh, you just made so many people so happy! Yeah, that's Stanley's pretzel order. It's very simple. Mm-hmm. Now while I was digging around in the superfan episode, I found a tag with Stanley and Michael. It's what you were just talking about, Angela. It was a deleted scene, but it got added back in to the end of Pretzel Day. We actually talked about this in our
太喜欢了，在拍摄剧本里，斯坦利有一句台词是他点椒盐卷饼，他是这么说的：一个咸味的，谢谢，要多加芥末！原来是这样。哦天哪，你让好多人太开心了！对，这就是斯坦利点的椒盐卷饼。非常简单。嗯哼。现在，当我在超级粉丝版里挖掘时，我发现了一个带有斯坦利和迈克尔的彩蛋。就是你刚才说的，安吉拉。那是一个被删减的片段，但它被加回到了“椒盐卷饼日”的结尾。我们实际上在我们的
breakdown of the initiation. That's probably why it was in my brain. I'm like I know I have seen them eating these pretzels. Yes, they are bonding and eating pretzels together. Here's a clip. What makes them feel good? I do not know. I mean they're just dough twisted up with some candy. They taste so good in my mouth. That's what she said. All right. 364 days till the next pretzel day. Isn't that great? Yeah. So great.
《入职培训》的解析中讨论过这个。这可能就是为什么它留在了我的脑海里。我想，我知道我见过他们吃这些椒盐卷饼。是的，他们在一起建立感情并吃着椒盐卷饼。这是一个剪辑片段。什么让他们感觉良好？我不知道。我的意思是它们只是卷着一些糖果的面团。它们在我的嘴里尝起来太棒了。她刚才就是这么说的。好吧。距离下一个椒盐卷饼日还有364天。不是很棒吗？对。太棒了。
So Leslie actually said that that is one of his favorite deleted scenes, because he got to do a that's what she said joke and then laugh with Michael. I mean, that's an iconic office moment. If your character has that moment with Michael. Yeah. Yeah. Jenny S from Pennsylvania wrote in and said, I would like to know what toppings Leslie would put on his pretzel on Pretzel Day. And thank you.
所以莱斯利实际上说过那是他最喜欢的被删减片段之一，因为他讲了一个“她刚才就是这么说的”的笑话，然后和迈克尔一起大笑。我的意思是，那是办公室的标志性时刻。如果你的角色能和迈克尔有这样的时刻。对。来自宾夕法尼亚州的珍妮·S写信说，我想知道莱斯利在“椒盐卷饼日”会把什么配料加在他的椒盐卷饼上。谢谢。
Well, we got the answer. Leslie said he would like anything with chocolate, caramel, and pecans. That sounds pretty tasty. Yes, very different from Stanley's pretzel order. Very different, more sweet, not so salty. Allison K. from Orange County and Megan E. from Indianapolis said, what would be our pretzel order? Oh, I love the cinnamon sugar pretzels. You know, you talked about pretzels earlier. I actually love the bites. Oh yeah, when you walk through the mall and they have that gal with the samples. Oh, forget about it.
嗯，我们得到了答案。莱斯利说他喜欢任何加了巧克力、焦糖和山核桃的东西。听起来挺好吃的。是的，和斯坦利点的椒盐卷饼很不一样。非常不同，更甜，没有那么咸。来自奥兰治县的艾莉森·K和来自印第安纳波利斯的梅根·E问，我们会点什么口味的椒盐卷饼？哦，我喜欢肉桂糖口味的椒盐卷饼。你知道，你刚才提到椒盐卷饼。我其实更喜欢一口大小的那种。哦对，当你走过商场时，有那个拿着试吃样品的大姐。哦，别提了。
Sam, what's your favorite pretzel topping? I don't know that I've ever had anything on a pretzel. Oh really? Yeah, this whole concept is foreign to me. Well, just salt. You can just love a salted pretzel. I do love dipping them in cheese, in melted cheese. That's it. There's your topping. There you go.
萨姆，你最喜欢的椒盐卷饼配料是什么？我不知道我有没有在椒盐卷饼上加过什么东西。哦，真的吗？对，整个概念对我来说都很陌生。好吧，就只有盐。你可能只是喜欢加盐的椒盐卷饼。我确实喜欢把它们蘸着芝士吃，蘸融化的芝士。就是这样。这就是你的配料。原来如此。
I'm gonna take Stanley's order. Oh, you like the little mustard. Mm-hmm. Do you like just a regular yellow mustard or a spicy mustard? I mean, if I could get a flight of different mustard, that would be awesome. I feel like I'm learning so much about you today. I really relate to Stanley. I like to keep it simple. I like just the salt. Okay. Yeah.
我要选斯坦利的那个。哦，你喜欢一点芥末。嗯哼。你喜欢普通的黄芥末还是辣芥末？我的意思是，如果我能买到一排不同口味的芥末就好了，那就太棒了。我觉得我今天对你有了很多了解。我真的很像斯坦利。我喜欢保持简单。我只喜欢盐。好的。对。
But I like it more in the pretzel shape than in the bite. And I'll tell you why. Tell me. Tell me why. Because when you get the full pretzel, some of it is soft and some of it's a little crunchy. Yeah. And you get both. And I like both. I like having a bite that's more soft and one that's crunchy. Whereas when you get the pretzel bites, they're great for size, they're great for travel, great for kids,
但我更喜欢整个椒盐卷饼的形状，而不是一口大小的那种。我告诉你为什么。告诉我。告诉我为什么。因为当你买一个完整的椒盐卷饼时，有些部分是软的，有些部分有点脆。对，两者兼得。两样我都喜欢。我喜欢有一口是比较软的，有一口是脆的。而当你买椒盐卷饼小块（Pretzel Bites）时，它们尺寸很好，方便携带，非常适合小孩子，
but you don't get the crunchy. You just get the soft. There were so many. That's what she said. I know. I know. But you never paused. So you couldn't's what she said. I know. I know. I know. But you never paused. So you couldn't interject one. Yeah. Okay. I hear you. The thing I like about the pretzel bites is that my favorite part of the pretzel is more
但你吃不到脆的。你只能吃到软的。有那么多。她刚才就是这么说的。我知道。我知道。但你从来没有停顿。所以你不能……她刚才就是这么说的。我知道。我知道。我知道。但你从来没有停顿。所以你没法插话。好吧。我懂你的意思。我喜欢椒盐卷饼小块的原因是，我最喜欢椒盐卷饼的部分是
of the sort of the soft part. No, the crunchy part. The hard exterior. And you think you get those more in the pretzel bites? I do. Cause it's more like it's, the soft dough is just in the middle and I feel like it's more encased in the.
那种比较软的部分。不，是脆的部分。硬的外壳。你觉得在椒盐卷饼小块里更能吃到这个吗？是的。因为更像是，软面团只在中间，我觉得它更多地包裹在……
I think you get more of an even bake, but I think with the big pretzel, you get more crunchy. The outer red, the outer edge of it sometimes is a lot harder than the little middle skinny part of it. Oh yeah. Yeah.
我觉得你能烤得更均匀，但我觉得对于大椒盐卷饼来说，你得到更多的脆皮。外面的红色部分，它外面的边缘有时比中间细细的部分要硬得多。哦，是的。对。
Yeah. And I think I like the same thing I like about string cheese is I just can just eat it like I pull it like a stick and I can eat it like a stick. I can walk around the mall with it. Anyway, I've thought way too much about this. I did a little deep dive on what your favorite pretzel shape says about you. Oh no. Well, you know mine. I do. Here are your choices. So, remember how I revealed what your favorite cupcake says about you?
对，我想我喜欢它的原因和喜欢手撕奶酪（string cheese）的原因一样，我可以像吃一根棍子一样吃它，像吃棍子一样拉着吃。我可以拿着它在商场里走来走去。总之，我对这个想得太多了。我做了一个小小的深入研究，看看你最喜欢的椒盐卷饼形状说明了什么。哦，不。好吧，你知道我的。我知道。以下是你的选择。所以，还记得我是如何揭示你最喜欢的纸杯蛋糕说明了什么吗？
Listen up everyone. Here are your choices. Now this applies to both a hard or a soft pretzel. Okay. Because soft pretzels don't come in all of these different sizes. So do you like a twist, a stick, a Bavarian, a ring, or a nugget? What does the Bavarian look like? I think that's the traditional pretzel shape that you're thinking of with the skinny bits and then the outer bit. Yes, that's what I thought.
大家听好了。以下是你的选择。这既适用于硬的椒盐卷饼，也适用于软的椒盐卷饼。好吧。因为软的椒盐卷饼没有所有这些不同的尺寸。所以你喜欢扭结形（twist）、长条形（stick）、巴伐利亚形（Bavarian）、环形（ring）还是块状（nugget）？巴伐利亚形长什么样？我想那就是你心目中的传统椒盐卷饼形状，有细细的部分和外面的部分。是的，我也是这么想的。
Okay, I'm Bavarian. Okay, Sam Cassie. I think Bavarian. I'll go twist. Twist, okay. I am clearly nugget. Yes. okay. I am clearly nugget. Yes. I even like a hard nugget.
好吧，我是巴伐利亚形。好吧，萨姆，卡茜呢？我想是巴伐利亚形。我选扭结形。扭结形，好的。我显然是块状。是的。好吧。我显然是块状。是的。我甚至喜欢硬块状的。
You know, like the kind they sell at Trader Joe's with the peanut butter inside. Yes. That's a nugget. Yes. And I like them soft as well. All right. Our Bavarians, you are indoorsy and laid back, yet social. You might be a romantic.
你知道的，就像他们在乔氏超市（Trader Joe's）卖的那种里面有花生酱的。是的。那是块状的。是的。而且我也喜欢软的。好吧。我们的巴伐利亚形朋友们，你们喜欢宅在家里，随性放松，但又很社交。你可能是个浪漫主义者。
Oh, Sam. Okay. We're indoorsy. I would not pick that for us. Uh twists. You are energetic, outdoorsy, and social. Dare I say Angela you might want to try a pretzel twist. Nuggets love being indoors, are laid back, and enjoy socializing, and like to engage others in lengthy conversations. That is not you. Are you kidding me?
哦，萨姆。好吧。我们喜欢宅着。我不会为我们选这个。呃，扭结形。你精力充沛，喜欢户外活动，也很社交。我敢说，安吉拉，你可能想尝试一下扭结形椒盐卷饼。块状爱好者喜欢宅家，性格随性，享受社交，喜欢让别人参与冗长的对话。那不是你。你在开玩笑吗？
If I like you, buckle in. You're going to get a lengthy conversation. Socializing? You love socializing? Oh yeah, that part's a no. Okay, it's a combo for you. All right. Well, just in case you're one of these others, I'll read them.
如果我喜欢你，系好安全带。你会得到一场冗长的对话。社交？你喜欢社交吗？哦，是的，那部分不是。好吧，这对你来说是个组合。好吧。以防万一你是这其中的其他类型，我来读一下。
If you like pretzel sticks, you are... Oh no, there's one more I missed. Rods. Anybody like a rod? That's what she said? Oh, the big long one. What's the difference between a rod and a stick? I think the sticks are tiny and skinny and the rods are long and thicker.
如果你喜欢椒盐卷饼条（stick），你就是……哦不，我漏掉了一个。棒状（rod）。有人喜欢棒状吗？她刚才就是这么说的？哦，那个又长又粗的。棒状（rod）和条状（stick）有什么区别？我觉得条状很小很细，而棒状很长很粗。
Oh, okay. Sorry. Noted both. Noted both. So many TWSSs. Okay. Well, anyway, if you like a pretzel stick, you are laid back yet confident and prefer to be by yourself. You might be a stick. I need to start eating some pretzel sticks.
哦，好吧。抱歉。两者都注意到了。两者都注意到了。有这么多“她刚才就是这么说的”。好吧。不管怎样，如果你喜欢椒盐卷饼条，你就是……哦不，随性却自信，更喜欢独处。你可能是个条状爱好者。我得开始吃一些椒盐卷饼条了。
If you're a pretzel rod person, you are laid back and outdoorsy. A party is not your idea of a good time. Instead, you would prefer to go camping or hiking with some good friends. Finally, if you love a pretzel ring, you are health conscious upbeat. You're a happy person, but you're concerned with your appearance. What? I don't know. Those two things don't seem to go together for me. If I'm concerned about my appearance, I'm stressed. All right. I saw a theme and what does your pretzel say about you?
如果你是个椒盐卷饼棒爱好者，你很随性，喜欢户外活动。聚会不是你觉得好玩的方式。相反，你更愿意和几个好朋友去露营或远足。最后，如果你喜欢椒盐卷饼环，你注重健康，乐观向上。你是个快乐的人，但你很在意自己的外表。什么？我不知道。这两件事在我看来似乎不太搭。如果我在意自己的外表，我就会压力很大。好吧。我发现了一个主题，你的椒盐卷饼说明了什么？
What is it? Most of us are laid back. I know. I know. We are laid back. If you like a pretzel, period, you're laid back. You're laid back. You're right.
是什么？我们大多数人都很随性。我知道。我知道。我们很随性。如果你喜欢椒盐卷饼，句号，你就是随性的。你很随性。你说的对。
The only person who's not laid back is a twister or a ring. Yeah. All right, Yeah. Mm-hmm. All right, everyone, back to Stanley. Another very memorable thing about Stanley is his basketball dribble. Oh, his basketball skills, man. Mm-hmm. I went back to the shooting draft and I found the description of that moment. This is right at the start of the game, right?
唯一不随性的人是喜欢扭结形或环形的人。对。好吧，是的。嗯哼。好吧，各位，回到斯坦利。关于斯坦利的另一个非常令人难忘的事情是他的篮球运球。哦，他的篮球技巧，天哪。嗯哼。我翻看了拍摄剧本，找到了那一幕的描述。这正好是在比赛开始时，对吧？
When Michael grabs the ball after Pam throws it in and the script says, quote, Michael fires the ball off to Stanley. Stanley takes off clumsily downfield. Michael is surprised at how bad he is, end quote. I found it very amusing that it says he goes down a field instead of down the court. Like, who wrote that description? Um, but that was all Leslie had to go off of clumsily. Yes. And then he came up with this whole physicality of how Stanley dribbles, and it is hilarious. Phyllis and I were reminiscing about this because,
当帕姆把球扔进来后，迈克尔抢到了球，剧本上说，引述，“迈克尔把球传给斯坦利。斯坦利笨拙地向场地另一头跑去。迈克尔对他的糟糕表现感到惊讶，”引述结束。我觉得很有趣的是，它说他是顺着“场地（field）”而不是顺着“球场（court）”跑。谁写这种描述的？嗯，但这已经是莱斯利仅有的依据了——笨拙。是的，然后他想出了斯坦利运球的整套肢体动作，这太搞笑了。菲利斯和我一直在回忆这个，因为，
and you know, you, me and Phyllis were all seated together in the background of the basketball episode. Yes, we were on that bench with a front row seat. And Phyllis was like, that is still so funny to her. She said that is her first memory of realizing the brilliance of Leslie David Baker. And I remember that too. I remember we all were just like, what? What is happening?
你知道的，你、我和菲利斯在篮球那一集的背景里都坐在一起。是的，我们在那个板凳上，占据了前排座位。菲利斯说，这在她看来依然非常搞笑。她说那是她第一次意识到莱斯利·大卫·贝克才华横溢的记忆。我也记得。我记得我们当时都觉得，什么？发生了什么？
That is amazing. So Leslie gets this question all the time. He's always asked, how did you come up with that? People want to know, is that how he really dribbles? And the answer is no. Leslie shared that that style of dribbling is modeled after someone he went to high school with. But that's all he'll say.
太棒了。所以莱斯利经常被问到这个问题。人们总问他：“你是怎么想出这个点子的？”大家都想知道，他真的是那样运球的吗？而答案是，并不是。莱斯利透露，他那种运球风格是模仿他高中时认识的一个人。但他也只能透露这么多了。
He can't name names. No. Oh, that's so good. I wonder if that person though. Knows? They know they went to high school with Leslie and they've probably seen the office. Do they know? I don't know. Yeah, I don't know. I mean, if you dribble like that, it's pretty distinct.
他不能说出名字。没错。噢，这太有意思了。不过我很好奇那个人知不知道？他们知道自己和莱斯利上过同一所高中，而且可能也看过这部剧。他们会知道吗？我不知道。是的，我不知道。我是说，如果你那样运球，辨识度还是蛮高的。
I know. We also got this question about Leslie's background work. Fan question from Jane in Woodstock, Georgia. She said, in talking heads that had the window facing the bullpen, I noticed that sometimes Stanley's head was completely still and sometimes you would see his head moving slightly as if he was actually doing work. Did Leslie have to be in the background for every single talking head or was there a green screen for times Leslie couldn't make it to set? Emily R. wrote in from Calgary to also say, did Leslie make overtime our bonuses
我也知道。我们还收到了关于莱斯利背景镜头的提问。来自佐治亚州伍德斯托克的粉丝简的提问。她说，在那些有窗户正对着办公区隔间的“面对镜头访谈”里，我注意到有时斯坦利的头一动不动，有时你会看到他的头微微晃动，就好像他真的在工作一样。莱斯利是不是得在每一个面对镜头访谈的背景里出镜，还是说在莱斯利没法到片场的时候用了绿幕？卡尔加里的艾米·R.发信来也想问，莱斯利因为一直当面对镜头访谈的背景
for being in the background of talking heads all the time? Well, you guys, no, he did not make overtime for that or get a bonus. He was amazing and steadfast and such a trooper for years and years. There was no green screen. That was always him. Always. Always. And here's the thing, everyone.
而拿过加班费或奖金吗？好吧，各位，不，他没有因为那个拿过加班费或奖金。多年来，他一直那么出色、坚定，而且非常敬业。根本没有什么绿幕。那一直都是他。一直都是。而且情况是这样的，各位。
We would do our talking heads in a clump either first thing in the morning or at the very end of the day. And then the sort of middle of the day was our group work. But if you weren't in the talking heads, you got to come in late or you got to leave early after the group work. But not Leslie. No. There were times when Leslie came in at five in the morning and he just sat in the background for two hours or he had to stay later at the end of the day to wrap out the Talking Heads
我们通常会在一大清早或者一整天快结束的时候，集中拍摄面对镜头访谈。然后一天的中间时段基本上是我们的群戏。但如果你不用拍面对镜头访谈，你就可以晚点来，或者拍完群戏后早点离开。但莱斯利不行。不。有时候莱斯利早上五点就来了，他得在背景里一坐就是两小时，或者为了配合收工去拍面对镜头访谈
and he never complained about it. No. And I think about that when they were deciding where we would all sit, we had no idea what shots we would be in the background of. I really lucked out because I was behind that big partition. So I was often not seen. That's why I would have to walk out to the copier so many times. But Leslie was right in the middle of the bullpen, but what he didn't realize is he was right behind that chair where they would end up
而不得不留到很晚，但他从来没有抱怨过。没错。当我想起当时他们在决定我们每个人坐哪儿的时候，我们根本不知道自己会出现在哪个镜头的背景里。我真的很幸运，因为我坐在那个大隔断后面。所以我经常不会被拍到。这就是为什么我得那么多次假装走到复印机旁。但莱斯利就坐在办公区的正中央，然而他没意识到的是，他正好坐在那张椅子后面，而那个位置最终会变成
having the conference room scenes. And no one could have known that. That was sort of found as the show went. And most of the time they could frame out Phyllis or they could frame out Creed who sort of sits in that same corridor. But they couldn't frame out Stanley. No, his desk is right there. Right there. Next, we have a fan question from Sarah B who is originally from Sweden but lives in Salt Lake City.
会议室场景的背景。谁也没料到这一点。这可以说是随着剧集的拍摄慢慢发现的。而且大多数时候，他们能把菲利斯切出镜头，或者把差不多坐在那个走廊的克里德切出镜头。但他们没法把斯坦利切出去。不，他的办公桌就在那儿。就在那儿。接下来，我们有来自萨拉·B.的粉丝提问，她原本来自瑞典，但现在住在盐湖城。
Sarah said, Leslie did a fabulous job as Stanley and as the most viewed background actor, I'm assuming he must have gotten quite bored. What did he do to entertain himself during all those shots? Well, Sarah, Leslie said he did a lot of online shopping. He once he even helped Phyllis shop for her Emmy dress. Yes. I remember him saying how thankful he was when we got internet. That was a game changer for him. But he would often look things up for us. If you said, just even in passing, like, oh, I need to get new bedding and I've been trying to look for like, you know, a blue comforter, he would look up things for you. I remember the year
萨拉说，莱斯利把斯坦利这个角色演得棒极了，作为出镜率最高的背景演员，我猜他一定觉得挺无聊的。在拍摄所有这些镜头时，他是怎么打发时间的？好吧，萨拉，莱斯利说他做了很多网上购物。有一次，他甚至帮菲利斯买艾美奖礼服。是的。我记得他说过，当我们有了网络时他是多么感激。这对他是颠覆性的改变。但他经常会帮我们查东西。如果你只是顺口说一句，比如，“噢，我想买套新床品，我一直在找那种，你知道的，蓝色的舒适被子”，他就会帮你查。我记得那一年
that Phyllis wanted to get Christmas stockings, and he searched so many Christmas stockings for her. She had a very specific thing she wanted. I remember it being a whole conversation. Well, you know, we also got another fan mail flurry, and it's about the relationship between the characters of Stanley and Phyllis. There are so many fan theories about them. There are articles, YouTube compilations, Reddit threads all about Phyllis and Stanley. Some say they were the true office BFFs. One of them said that they were each other's work spouse, and that really cracked me up.
菲利斯想买圣诞长筒袜，他帮她搜了超级多的圣诞长筒袜。她对想要的东西有非常具体的要求。我记得这成了一个专门讨论的话题。好吧，你知道的，我们还收到了另一波粉丝来信，是关于斯坦利和菲利斯这两个角色之间的关系的。关于他们有太多的粉丝理论了。有文章、油管混剪、红迪网上的讨论串，全都是关于菲利斯和斯坦利的。有人说他们是办公室里真正的最佳死党。其中一人说他们是彼此的工作伴侣，这真的把我逗乐了。
I think that's true. I found two examples that I loved. There are many, but I want to share two, of Phyllis and Stanley being each other's work spouse. My absolute favorite is a very small moment. It's from the episode Blood Drive, and they're trying to get free cookies from the blood mobile. I remember that. And Stanley goes in first, and Phyllis is lurking outside the blood mobile like waiting. Let's hear it.
我觉得是真的。我找到了两个我超喜欢的例子。例子有很多，但我想分享两个关于菲利斯和斯坦利是彼此工作伴侣的例子。我绝对最喜欢的是一个非常小的细节。出自《献血》那一集，他们俩试图从流动献血车那里弄到免费饼干。我记得那个。斯坦利先走了进去，而菲利斯像在埋伏一样在流动献血车外面等着。我们听听看。
Pardon me, may I have a chocolate chip cookie I gave blood earlier and I'm still feeling woozy. Of course. That's weird. You got a cotton ball and tape and we've been using Band-Aids. Oh, I feel so woozy. I I just need my band-aids. Oh, damn. So, they both put a cotton ball in tape, and then when they went in, they found out that particular blood mobile doesn't do it like that. It's very funny. And it's so funny. Phyllis is like, damn it. Anyway, it just cracked me up. I love the
打扰一下，能给我一块巧克力曲奇吗？我刚才献了血，现在还是觉得头晕目眩。当然。这太奇怪了。你拿的是棉球和胶带，而我们一直用的是创可贴。噢，我觉得好晕。我……我只是需要我的创可贴。噢，该死。所以，他们俩都拿了棉球和胶带，然后当他们走进去时，才发现那辆特定的流动献血车根本不是那样操作的。这太搞笑了。真的太好笑了。菲利斯当时说：“该死。”总之，这把我逗乐了。我太喜欢
two of them. But there is one fan theory that we got a ton of mail about. We're going to get to the bottom of it today. Several of you wrote in, like Rocco from Canada and many others, saying, did Stanley and Phyllis ever hook up? Is Stanley the person Phyllis is talking about when she said she hooked up with someone in the office. Angela, I know you're very excited about this because I got a very excited message from you yesterday saying you have an answer. I do.
他们俩了。但有一个我们收到海量信件的粉丝理论。我们今天要一探究竟。你们中的好几个人，比如来自加拿大的罗科和其他许多人写信问，斯坦利和菲利斯真的有一腿吗？斯坦利是不是菲利斯提到过的那个在办公室里和某人有过一夜情的人？安吉拉，我知道你对这个超级兴奋，因为我昨天收到了你发来的一条超级激动的消息，说你找到了答案。我是找到了。
This was like your mom detective moment about what does Stanley have on his pretzel. Yes, that was my obsessive moment this week. Well, first of all, there's an article on Looper based off a fan theory. The fan theory was on Reddit. The user was joeh595, who started a thread that suggested the two could have had a sexual relationship before the series was filmed. So this would have been a hookup that even predates the pilot. They didn't hook up during any part of the show we're watching. Yes, according to this fan theory. theory. One piece of evidence to support this is in season two's sexual harassment. Toby reminds the staff that they must disclose any romantic relationships
这就像是你的“妈妈侦探”高光时刻，就像查证斯坦利在椒盐卷饼上加了什么一样。是的，这就是我这周的强迫症时刻。好吧，首先，在鲁珀网站上有一篇基于某个粉丝理论的文章。这个粉丝理论来自红迪网。发帖的网友是joeh595，他发起了一个讨论串，暗示这两人在剧集拍摄之前可能就谈过恋爱了。所以这意味着他们俩的露水情缘甚至发生在试播集之前。在我们在看的这部剧的任何阶段，他们都没有过一腿。是的，根据这个粉丝理论。理论。支持这一点的证据之一是第二季的《性骚扰》那一集。托比提醒全体员工，必须申报任何
people have with coworkers. And then Phyllis promptly says, does that include a one night stand? Suggesting that she had a tryst with someone working close by. The show never reveals who it could be, but a lot of people think it might be Stanley because one, they say, well, they both have a history of adultery. Stanley famously cheats on his wife several times. And then some people pointed out that in the episode The Chump, Michael says, why is it okay for Phyllis to cheat on her diet? And he makes this pause and he pivots. And they think that abrupt pivot means that Michael knew that Phyllis
与同事的浪漫恋情。接着菲利斯立刻脱口而出：“这包括一夜情吗？”这暗示她曾与在附近工作的人有过私情。剧集从未透露那个人可能是谁，但很多人觉得可能是斯坦利，因为第一，他们说，两人都有出轨的历史。斯坦利出了名地背着妻子出轨好几次。然后有些人指出，在《冤大头》那一集里，迈克尔说：“为什么菲利斯破坏减肥计划就可以？”接着他顿了一下，然后岔开话题。他们认为这个生硬的转折意味着迈克尔知道菲利斯
cheated on Bob Vance, but then had to pivot to cover it. I don't think Phyllis cheated on Bob Vance. I absolutely don't think Phyllis cheated on Bob Vance. I absolutely don't think Phyllis cheated on Bob Vance at all. So this leads me to my mom detective moment because not only is this fan theory, but Leslie shared that one of his favorite scenes that he did with Phyllis ever on the whole show was unfortunately deleted. And he said it's where Stanley and Phyllis are having cocktails at their desk. Yes, Angela. And I remember you said, oh, I want to find that. I'd love to play Leslie's
对不起鲍勃·万斯，但随后不得不转移话题来掩饰。我不认为菲利斯背叛了鲍勃·万斯。我绝对不认为菲利斯背叛了鲍勃·万斯。我绝对不认为菲利斯背叛了鲍勃·万斯。所以这就引出了我的“妈妈侦探”时刻，因为不仅有这个粉丝理论，而且莱斯利还透露，他在整部剧中和菲利斯拍过的、自己最喜欢的场景之一不幸被删了。他说那是斯坦利和菲利斯在办公桌前喝鸡尾酒的戏。是的，安吉拉。我记得你说过：“噢，我想找找看。我很想播放莱斯利
favorite scene with Phyllis. And so you went down this road. You're looking for it. What episode was that? Yeah, because I'm like, if they're drinking after hours together, does that support this theory that they have a relationship? Well, I couldn't find it anywhere. I could not find this deleted scene. So I reached out to Dave Rogers. He immediately, of course, was like, Angela, that was a tag written for Doomsday. I can't believe that. I can't believe he was like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah, deleted Stanley Phillips having cocktails at their desk. Doomsday tag. Yeah, Doomsday
最喜欢的和菲利斯合作的场景。”于是你就顺着这条线索找下去了。你在找它。那是哪一集？对啊，因为我在想，如果他们下班后在一起喝酒，这是否能证明他们确实有某种关系的理论？好吧，我到处都找不到。我找不到这个被删掉的场景。于是我联系了戴夫·罗杰斯。他当然立刻就说：“安吉拉，那是为《末日》那一集写的一个片尾彩蛋。”我简直不敢相信。我简直不敢相信他说：“噢，对，对，对，被删掉的斯坦利和菲利斯在办公桌前喝鸡尾酒。《末日》的彩蛋。”对，《末日》的彩蛋。
tag. He said it's not in deleted scenes. It's probably in the shooting draft. So I go to the shooting draft. It's not there. I go to the candy bag alts. It's not there. Finally, I go to an early table draft that we had and there it is. There is the tag and I guess they actually shot it. Wow. And here is what happens in the tag. Are you ready? Yes. So this is going to reveal if they have ever hooked up. Yes. Oh, my gosh. So in the doomsday episode, if you remember, Stanley pulls out a bottle of brandy that he says he's been saving just for a day like this. OK. OK. Stanley's telling Phyllis a story.
他说这不在被删片段里。它可能在拍摄剧本里。于是我去找了拍摄剧本。里面没有。我又去找了糖果袋备选台词。还是没有。最后，我找到了一份我们早期拥有的围读剧本，然后找到了。彩蛋就在那里，而且我猜他们真的拍了。哇哦。以下是彩蛋里发生的事情。准备好了吗？好的。所以这就将揭晓他们是否真的有过一腿。好的。噢天哪。所以在《末日》那一集里，如果你还记得的话，斯坦利拿出一瓶白兰地，说他一直留着等今天这样的日子再喝。好吧。好吧。斯坦利正在给菲利斯讲一个故事。
They're a little tipsy. He's saying, you know, the recruiter told me my eyes were too bad to enlist. Phyllis is like, I'm sorry, it sounds like you really wanted to go to Vietnam. Can I have some more of that brandy? This is a ridiculous conversation. Stanley says, sure can and don't call me brandy. And then they start laughing. And then Stanley goes to pour Phyllis a drink and it overflows. He says, whoops-a-daisy, Stanley's drunk. And he looks at the spill and says, have you ever seen anything so sad? And they laugh. And then Phyllis dabs a little bit of Brandy behind her ear. Where's this going? She says, this drives Bob crazy. Then she starts wincing and goes, ow, ow, ow, my eczema. Ow. Okay, it's better. Stanley goes, you okay? And Phyllis says, yes, thank you
他们有点微醺。他说：“你知道的，当兵体检的人告诉我，我的视力太差不能参军。”菲利斯说：“我很遗憾，听起来你真的很想去越南。我能再来点那种白兰地吗？”这对话太荒谬了。斯坦利说：“当然可以，别叫我白兰地。”然后他们笑了起来。接着斯坦利给菲利斯倒酒，结果倒溢出来了。他说：“哎呀，斯坦利喝醉了。”他看着洒出来的酒说：“你见过比这更让人伤心的事吗？”他们笑了。然后菲利斯在耳后沾了一点点白兰地。这对话要走向何方？她说：“这把鲍勃迷得神魂颠倒。”接着她开始龇牙咧嘴，说道：“噢，噢，噢，我的湿疹。噢。好吧，好多了。”斯坦利问：“你没事吧？”菲利斯说：“是的，谢谢
for asking. Stanley says, you are welcome. I'm on the edge of my seat right now. Then there is a long pause. What? And then here's something they say at the same time. Overlapping dialogue. Overlapping dialogue after a long pause and drinking brandy. Stanley says, how's Bob doing? Phyllis says, I've never been with a black man before. What? What? Wow. And then there is a long beat and Stanley says, good night. And he leaves feeling a little awkward and exits. Oh my gosh, there's so much to unpack. There is so much to unpack. Okay, so first of all, it answers the question. They have not hooked up before. They've never hooked up, but I feel like it sort of teases that in this moment, Phyllis might have been up for it. Yes! Is
你关心。”斯坦利说：“不客气。”我现在的神经都紧绷起来了。接着是一段长长的沉默。什么？然后是他们同时说出的话。重叠的台词。在长久的沉默和喝了白兰地之后出现的重叠台词。斯坦利说：“鲍勃最近怎么样？”菲利斯说：“我以前从没和黑人男性在一起过。”什么？什么？哇哦。接着是一段长时间的停顿，斯坦利说：“晚安。”然后他感觉有点尴尬地离开了。噢天哪，信息量太大了。信息量实在是太大了。好吧，首先，它回答了这个问题。他们以前没有过一腿。他们从来没有过一腿，但我觉得它某种程度上暗示了，在这当口，菲利斯其实是愿意的。没错！
this her I knew what I was doing Pam moment? I think maybe so. And you know, so many fan theories point to these moments where there was tenderness between them even though they got on each other's nerves. Yes. You know, I mean, Stanley whittled that whole thing for her. Phyllis, as a chicken, or whatever, as a bird person in the finale. I mean, he clearly cares for her. But yeah, I'm telling you, the long pause is where everything happens. Oh my gosh, put that on a mug. So there was my mom detective moment. I loved it. Thank you, Dave, for pointing me in the right direction.
这难道就是她的“我心知肚明”的高光时刻吗？我觉得也许是的。而且你知道，有那么多的粉丝理论都指向这些充满温情的时刻，尽管他们平时总是互相惹毛对方。没错。你知道的，我是说，斯坦利为她精雕细琢了那个东西。在结尾时，菲利斯打扮成小鸡，或者别的什么鸟类。我是说，他显然很在乎她。但是，好吧，我跟你说，那段漫长的沉默就是一切发生的地方。噢天哪，把这话印在马克杯上。这就是我的“妈妈侦探”时刻。我太喜欢了。谢谢戴夫为我指明了正确的方向。
But yeah, I mean, little bit of brandy, dot dot dot, but nothing happened. And I think that settles it that they had never hooked up. Well, in real life, Leslie and Phyllis were very good friends. They are still good friends. In fact, Leslie said his favorite person to do scenes with is Phyllis because she's an amazing actress and because they are friends in real life. And we reached out to Phyllis to ask her about working with Leslie and she said this, Leslie is a real stand-up guy with character and principles and a sense of humor that just adds charm and wit when being with him.
不过说真的，来点白兰地，省略号，但什么都没发生。我觉得这彻底证实了他们从来没有过一腿。好吧，在现实生活中，莱斯利和菲利斯是非常要好的朋友。他们现在依然是好朋友。事实上，莱斯利说过，他最喜欢和谁对戏，那个人就是菲利斯，因为她是个出色的演员，而且他们在现实生活中就是朋友。我们联系了菲利斯，向她询问和莱斯利合作的感受，她是这么说的：“莱斯利是个堂堂正正的人，有品格、有原则，还有一种幽默感，和他在一起时，总能增添无限魅力和风趣。”
She confirmed that they did a lot of online shopping together, and she said they would also run to Walmart and do errands together if there was ever a long break in filming. Could you imagine? I know. I know. Like if they weren't in a couple of scenes in the afternoon, they'd just go hop over to Walmart together? It's so adorable.
她证实了他们一起在网上买了很多东西，并说如果拍摄间隙有很长的休息时间，他们还会一起跑去沃尔玛办杂货差事。你能想象吗？我懂。我懂。就像如果他们在下午的几场戏里没戏份，他们就会一起溜去沃尔玛？这太可爱了。
And they also would show up for each other at their premieres and things. I mean, I saw a picture that Leslie went with Phyllis for her, the OA, the show on Netflix, her premiere. Yeah. He did the red carpet with her. But we all used to get paired up to do press on the show. You know, I would get paired up with Brian or Rain. You would get paired up with John quite a bit usually. And Phyllis and Leslie were always paired up together. I found an interview of the two
而且他们还会出席彼此的首映礼之类的活动。我是说，我看到一张照片，莱斯利陪着菲利斯去参加网飞的剧集《先见之明》的首映礼。是的。他和她一起走了红毯。不过我们以前在剧组总是会被凑成对去跑宣传。你知道的，我经常被和布莱恩或雷恩凑成对。你通常基本上总是和约翰凑成对。而菲利斯和莱斯利总是被分到一块儿。我找到了一个采访，是他们两个
of them on the red carpet for the BAFTA T years ago. They were very excited about things that were coming up for their characters on the show. And I watched the whole interview. It just warmed my heart because you could just, I don't know, you could hear their love for their show. You could hear their familiarity and friendship. And I thought I'd share it. Hello sir, how are you doing? Huge office freak.
多年前在英国电影学院奖红毯上的采访。他们对剧中各自角色即将迎来的发展感到非常兴奋。我看完了整个采访。这真的温暖了我的心，因为你能，我不知道，你能听到他们对这部剧的热爱。你能感受到他们的熟悉感和友谊。我想把它分享出来。你好，先生，最近怎么样？超级办公室狂热粉。
Yes, it's one of my favorite shows. Okay, what can we expect this year? Well, we know. Wait, all the spoilers. Well, you already saw Thursday night what happened. I have issues. I know, he's showing up. I'm cheating and tearing up cars and just, you know,
是的，这是我最喜欢的剧之一。好的，我们今年可以期待些什么？好吧，我们知道。等等，全是剧透。好吧，你周四晚上已经看到发生什么了。我有麻烦了。我知道，他出现了。我出轨了，把车砸了，然后，你知道的，
I'm having a mid-life man crisis, I don't know. Are you happy with that storyline? I am, because it was so much fun to do. And it was unexpected and unpredictable, and it surprised me, it surprised the other cast members, and it was fun to do and it was unexpected and unpredictable and it surprised me, it surprised the other cast members and it was fun to do. It's always nice because it keeps it fresh. Absolutely.
我正经历中年男人的危机，我不知道。你对这个故事线满意吗？我很满意，因为拍起来太好玩了。而且它既出人意料又难以捉摸，它震惊了我，震惊了其他演员，拍起来太好玩了，而且它既出人意料又难以捉摸，它震惊了我，震惊了其他演员，拍起来太好玩了。这总是很棒，因为它能保持新鲜感。绝对是的。
It keeps it fresh, yeah. You know, it gets the structure active tops. You guys actually stick to the script more than we assume you do, right? Well usually we lay the script out, it depends on the director and his style of directing but they would like for us to lay it down as written and then then they say, okay, play with it. And then we were allowed. And then it goes places. You never dreamed. Oh, I loved that. You got to share that, Angela, so that people can watch the whole thing. That was just a little snippet. I will. I think I just love that you hear Leslie's laugh and you know he's just full of joy and so not like his Stanley character and I thought it was nice to hear that.
保持新鲜感，是的。你知道的，这让剧情结构保持活跃。你们其实比我们想象的更严格地遵循剧本，对吧？嗯，通常我们会按写好的剧本走，这取决于导演和他的导演风格，但他们希望我们按写好的台词来演，然后他们会说：“好吧，自由发挥吧。”然后我们就获准了。接着剧情就会走向一些你做梦也想不到的方向。噢，我太喜欢了。安吉拉，你得分享这个，好让大家能看全片。那只是个小片段。我会的。我想我只是喜欢听到莱斯利的笑声，你知道他是充满喜悦的，一点也不像他演的斯坦利那个角色，我觉得听到这个感觉真好。
Well Phyllis reminded me of another thing about Leslie. She said whenever they were at a work party and he would meet someone for the first time without missing a beat if he saw them at the next work party he could remember their name. That's amazing. Yes. That's a talent. I remember that about him. It was pretty incredible actually because we would meet a lot of people at those events and he would remember everybody. Yeah. Well all right everyone we're getting to the end here but we did get a fan question from Matt T in Allendale Michigan who said, do we know how many crossword puzzles Leslie slash Stanley worked on over the years? Well, first of all, Leslie said he really did do the crossword puzzles, and he did lots of them.
好吧，菲利斯让我想起了关于莱斯利的另一件事。她说每当他们在公司的派对上第一次遇到某人时，只要下次公司派对时见到对方，他甚至不用停顿一下就能叫出对方的名字。这太厉害了。是的。这绝对是天赋。我记得他这一点。其实真的挺了不起的，因为我们在那些活动上会遇到很多人，而他能记住每一个人。好吧，好了各位，我们要接近尾声了，不过我们确实收到了来自密歇根州艾伦代尔的粉丝马特·T.的提问，他说，我们知道莱斯利也就是斯坦利这些年来做过多少填字游戏吗？嗯，首先，莱斯利说他确实做了填字游戏，而且做了很多很多。
Yes, one time he was asked this, and he sort of did the math. He said, okay, over a nine year period, about five a year, over, hmm, I think 60 books we went through. 60 books of crossword puzzles. That's what he said. Well, Leslie also shared that he actually fell asleep at his desk, just like Stanley did. I mean, can you blame him?
是的，有一次有人问他这个问题，他大概算了一下。他说：“好吧，在九年的时间里，一年大约五个，超过了，嗯，我想我们做完了60本书。”60本填字游戏书。他是这么说的。好吧，莱斯利还透露，他其实真的在办公桌前睡着过，就像斯坦利那样。我是说，这能怪他吗？
Coming in at five in the morning, sitting back there? He said when he had the mask on for the Halloween episode, he fell asleep. And also once after a Christmas party, he fell asleep on the couch. I kind of remember that. I do too. Yeah. We just tiptoed around him while he napped. I remember that. I do too. Yeah. We just tiptoed around him while he napped. I remember that. I do too. I remember that. Well, you know, as we talk about the character
早上五点钟来，坐在后排？他说万圣节那集他戴着面具时就睡着了。而且有一次圣诞派对后，他也曾在沙发上睡着。我好像有点印象。我也是。对啊。我们在他打盹时都蹑手蹑脚的。我记得那个。我也是。对啊。我们在他打盹时都蹑手蹑脚的。我记得那个。我也是。我记得。好吧，你知道的，当我们谈论斯坦利这个角色时，
Stanley, I always love to know what episodes or scenes our castmates hold dear or have great memories of their time filming The Office. And Leslie said his favorite Stanley-focused scene was when Michael Scott tried reviving Stanley from his heart attack. And his favorite non-focused scene was when Michael Scott tried reviving Stanley from his heart attack. And his favorite non-focused Stanley episode was Phyllis and Bob Vance's wedding. He said he also really enjoyed the episode where Dwight and Clark roll him in bubble wrap. Yes, he talked about that in his Sterema Gettin interview. He did.
我总是很想知道我们的演员搭档们对拍摄《办公室》的时光，有哪些珍视的剧集或场景，或者有着怎样美好的回忆。莱斯利说，他最喜欢的以斯坦利为核心的场景是迈克尔·斯科特试图抢救突发心脏病的斯坦利的那段。而他最喜欢的非核心场景……等下，他最喜欢的以斯坦利为核心的剧集是菲利斯和鲍勃·万斯的婚礼。他说他也很喜欢德怀特和克拉克把他用气泡膜裹起来的那一集。是的，他在自己的“Sterema Gettin”采访中聊过这个。他确实聊过。
And then we talked to Clark and it was also one of his favorite episodes. Finally, I thought we could end with Stanley's Where Are They Now? You know there's a lot of theories about where each of the characters are and pretty unanimously everyone thinks Stanley's very happy in Florida. And I think Stanley answers it the best in the finale. He says, yes I'm living in Florida now, a little town called Florida City, just on the edge of the Everglades. The man who delivered my divorce papers came by fanboat, which was kind of fun. I sit on my porch all day, carving birds.
然后我们和克拉克聊过，这也是他最喜欢的剧集之一。最后，我想我们可以用“斯坦利现在在哪里”来结尾。你知道的，有很多关于每个角色现状的理论，而且几乎众口一词，大家都觉得斯坦利在佛罗里达过得非常开心。我觉得斯坦利在结尾时回答得最好。他说：“是的，我现在住在佛罗里达，一个小镇叫佛罗里达城，就在大沼泽地的边缘。给我送离婚协议书的那个人是坐风扇船来的，还挺好玩的。我整天坐在门廊上，雕刻小鸟。”
Well, there you have it. That's all about Stanley Hudson in honor of Pretzel Day this Saturday. Make sure you get yourself some free pretzels. It'll mean you're laid back. That's right. Have a laid back Saturday. Have a laid back Saturday. Thanks so much for writing in, you guys.
好了，你们听到了。这就是本周六为了庆祝椒盐卷饼日而盘点的斯坦利·哈德森。确保你们自己去买一些免费的椒盐卷饼。那意味着你心态很放松。没错。度过一个悠闲放松的周六。度过一个悠闲放松的周六。非常感谢大家写信给我们。
And thanks so much to Leslie for telling us about his audition and sharing with us about his time on the show. We love you guys, and we hope you have a good one. See you next time! Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil.
非常感谢莱斯利跟我们讲述他的试镜经历，并和我们分享他在剧组的时光。我们爱你们，希望你们过得愉快。下次见！感谢收听“办公室淑女”。“办公室淑女”是奥德赛频道的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾因斯利·巴巴科。奥德赛频道的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯·伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。“办公室淑女”由克里斯·巴塞尔进行混音和母带制作。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。